Sometimes you've got to dig deep. Sometimes you've got to look in the glass and you've got to ask yourself, how much do I want this? Why did I show up today? Why did I want to put it all on the line? What are my goals and what am I willing to do to reach them? Now what you look at me and I want you to repeat. S M A R T L E S S smart less smart Less Smart Less Let's Go! Smart Smart Smart Smart Less Smart
有时你必须深入挖掘。有时你必须看着镜子问自己，我到底有多渴望这个？我今天为什么要出现？我为什么要把一切都押上？我的目标是什么，为了达成目标我愿意做什么？现在，看着我，我要你们重复。S M A R T L E S S smart less smart Less Smart Less 上吧！Smart Smart Smart Smart Less Smart
Are we rolling Jimmy. Shon. Yeah. Shon. Shon. Shon. Wait, you guys, this is crazy that you're speaking British accents. Go ahead. Why are you doing?
我们在录了吗，吉米？肖恩。对。肖恩。肖恩。肖恩。等等，你们俩太疯狂了，居然在学英国口音。说吧。你们在干嘛？
I know, I know. Wait, Shon, you London. Oh my gosh. No. Well, Jason's not. Neither of you go. That's both of this terrible. No, that now that's great. It's going to be so insulting to our guest. But wait, let's get.
我知道，我知道。等等，肖恩，你这个伦敦人。哦天哪。不。好吧，杰森不是。你们俩都不是。太糟糕了。不，现在这太棒了。这对我们的嘉宾太侮辱了。不过等等，让我们……
Of course, is our guest British? Oh, no. What, what, what made you think that the 50 times that he went like, I don't know. Wait, what are you saying? Seani, next week, I know we should have do this on the podcast, but dinner in New York, yes, Tuesday. Guys, what are we doing? What are you doing? You're not doing anything. You're staying in home. Yeah, Tuesday, 100% in New York, dinner, right?
当然，我们的嘉宾是英国人吗？哦，不。什么，什么让你觉得他那50次的腔调是——我不知道。等等，你在说什么？肖尼，下周，我知道我们不该在播客里说这个，但在纽约吃晚饭，对，周二。伙计们，我们在干嘛？你们在干嘛？你们什么也没干。你们待在家里。对，周二，百分之百在纽约，吃晚饭，对吧？
Let's hold on, let's hear we're making plans. You guys have your roller dicks is out, you wanna wait for that? Or enter it? Oh, I'm sorry. Do you wanna talk about golf? No, I just, I'm not gonna make You guys have your roller dicks is out. You wanna wait for that? Or enter it? Oh, I'm sorry. Do you wanna talk about golf? No, I just, I'm not gonna make plans with my buddy on the listeners time.
等一下，听着，我们在计划事情。你们的记事本拿出来了，你们想等那个？还是现在记？哦，抱歉。你想聊高尔夫吗？不，我只是，我不会跟……你们的记事本拿出来了。你们想等那个？还是现在记？哦，抱歉。你想聊高尔夫吗？不，我只是，我不会在听众的时间里和我的哥们儿做计划。
Hey, what are the rules? Jay, why don't you come out and join us? Finally, come out. No, because I'm married. I've had two children and it would just be too disruptive. But they won't, they won't know that. What's in New York? To New York.
嘿，规则是什么？杰伊，你为什么不出来加入我们？终于肯出来了。不，因为我结婚了。我有两个孩子，这会太受打扰了。但他们不会，他们不会知道的。纽约有什么？去纽约。
To New York. I already tried to get him to come to New York and he just gave a classic Jason. No, I don't want to. Yeah, well my feelings. And I apologize for that. I've had long discussions with my wife over the last 12 hours and what I need to work on is checking in with other people that are associated with the plan that might not see it through the prism of one. There you go. So maybe ask them what they would like. Right.
去纽约。我已经试图让他去纽约了，而他只是给出了一个典型的杰森式回答：不，我不想去。好吧，我的感受。我为此道歉。在过去的12个小时里，我和我妻子进行了长时间的讨论，我需要改进的是，去和计划中涉及的其他可能不会从单一角度看待问题的人沟通。就是这样。所以也许问问他们想要什么。对。
And then, you know, because I just think, well, they're asking my opinion. So it's just about me, how do I personally, well, my personal opinion is, no, I wouldn't like to do that. But if I check in with you, I might change that, you know? Right. If you go like, or maybe, and you can,
然后呢，你知道的，因为我只想着，嗯，他们在问我的意见。所以这只是关于我，我个人怎么看，好吧，我个人的意见是，不，我不想那样做。但如果我和你沟通，我可能会改变想法，你知道吗？对。如果你说，或者也许，你可以……
even before you check in, you can go like, or you maybe, and you can even before you check in, you can go like, hey, maybe this is something that somebody else wants, and it's not just, I don't want, I want, I don't want, I want. Yeah. And you go like, There's a we in this world. Yeah.
甚至在你沟通之前，你就可以说，或者也许，你甚至在你沟通之前，你就可以说，嘿，也许这是别人想要的，而不只是，我不想要，我想要，我不想要，我想要。对。然后你会说，这个世界还有一个“我们”。对。
You know what I mean? Yeah, no, it's a great note, and I think I'm learning it just in time at 54. Jade, do you want to go out to dinner next week? Yeah, no, thanks. All dog news. I'm not going to be in town, but if you guys want to zoom me in from the table, that would be a right.
你知道我的意思吗？对，不，这是一个很好的提醒，我想我在54岁时终于及时学会了。杰伊，你下周想出去吃晚饭吗？对，不，谢谢。全是狗粮。我不在城里，但如果你们想在桌旁通过Zoom连线我，那倒也行。
I love to watch you. Wait, I want to say one thing. As you know, smartness media launched bad dates, which is now right now, with Jameela Jamil, which is fantastic. It's a great show. But we have a new name. and just Jack and Will launches June 22nd. Well, I wanted to say that so that you didn't have to promote your own show. No, no, sorry, it's Will. It's our show.
我喜欢看你。等等，我想说一件事。如你们所知，SmartLess Media推出了由杰米拉·杰米尔主持的播客《Bad Dates》，现在正在播出，非常棒。这是一个很棒的节目。但我们有一个新名字。还有《Just Jack and Will》将于6月22日上线。好吧，我想说这个，这样你就不用宣传你自己的节目了。不，不，抱歉，是《Will》。这是我们的节目。
It's our show. No, no, no, no. Will, do you and Jack Black are doing a podcast? No, you do. No, no. It's the characters Jack and Will from Will and Grace. So it's Sean Hayes and Eric McCormick doing. We're doing, we're doing, we're doing, we're doing, we're doing, we're doing, we're doing Will and Grace. So it's Sean Hayes and Eric McCormick doing.
这是我们的节目。不，不，不，不。威尔，你和杰克·布莱克在做一个播客？不，不是。不，不。那是《威尔和格蕾丝》里的角色杰克和威尔。所以是肖恩·海斯和埃里克·麦柯马克在做。我们在做，我们在做，我们在做，我们在做，我们在做，我们在做《威尔和格蕾丝》的重看播客。所以是肖恩·海斯和埃里克·麦柯马克在做。
We're doing it. We're doing it. And it's a rewatch podcast of Will and Grace. I'm, Sean, I'm getting to it. I want to say it so you don't have to. So you can take in all the praise you deserve. Do you know what I'm most excited about with that podcast is that? Sanger.
我们在做。我们在做。这是一个重看《威尔和格蕾丝》的播客。肖恩，我正要说到这。我想替你说出来，这样你就不用自己说了。这样你就可以尽情接受你应得的赞美了。你知道我对那个播客最兴奋的是什么吗？桑格。
No, to coming on. My, my daughter. No, actually, actually, listen, I think this, this means I to coming on. My daughter actually, listen, I think this means I'm coming on. My daughter's, your good friends and my granny and maple, 16 and 11 have never seen Will and Grace and their bananas about you. So I just keep thinking, wait till they see you, do your thing.
不，是来参加。我的，我的女儿。不，事实上，事实上，听着，我觉得这，这意味着我来参加。我的女儿们，你的好粉丝，格兰妮和枫叶，16岁和11岁，从未看过《威尔和格蕾丝》，她们为你疯狂。所以我一直在想，等到她们看你表演的时候。
And so this is gonna give us a great chance to start watching the show together. Yeah, that's a great. And then listening to the podcast, uh, doing the rewatch. And then coming on, maybe I'll bring them both on and we'll give you, we'll give you notes. That would be, you know, so fun. You guys aren't locked yet on those episodes, right? If we, if we recording them now, we recorded a bunch of, no, no, no, sorry, the willing grace episodes, if we give you notes, you know, we can rest your stuff. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. It'll match. It'll match. By the way, it's the 25th anniversary of willing grace this year. Right? Silver anniversary. Isn't that crazy? Yeah.
所以这会给我们一个很好的机会一起开始看这个节目。对，太棒了。然后听播客，重看。然后来参加，也许我把她俩都带来，我们会给你，我们会给你提意见。那会，你知道的，太有趣了。你们那些剧集还没最终敲定吧，对吧？如果我们，如果我们现在在录制，我们录了一堆，不，不，不，抱歉，《威尔和格蕾丝》的剧集，如果我们给你提意见，你知道的，我们可以修改你们的东西。好吧。对。会匹配的。会匹配的。顺便说一句，今年是《威尔和格蕾丝》开播25周年。对吧？银婚纪念。是不是很疯狂？对。
Is that over five years ago? You know what? Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh Jimmy we're always yesterday. Yeah. Oh, no way. Yeah. Where at Pine Golf? He was playing with Al Michaels or other good friend. He said, say hi to Shane. I think you guys are doing a good job on the, on the, he said, he said, Shane, I loved working with Shane. Yeah. He was the best. I'll never forget him. He said, yeah. He said, never forgets the best. And we, and we said, we, he said, I'll never get him. We said, who? And he said, what? Do you know what I mean? So Tracy, that's the director of Willing Grace. Well, he's a friend and, you know, he's directed every episode of Willing Grace.
那是五年多前吗？你知道吗，呃……吉米，我们昨天才刚聊过。对。哦，不会吧。在哪？在松树高尔夫球场？他和我们的另一个好朋友阿尔·迈克尔斯一起打球。他说，代我向肖恩问好。他说，我觉得你们在……做得很好，他说，他说，肖恩，我喜欢和肖恩合作。对。他是最好的。我永远不会忘记他。他说，对。他说，永远不会忘记最棒的。然后我们，我们说，我们，他说，我永远不会忘了他。我们说，谁？他说，什么？你知道我的意思吗？所以特雷西，那是《威尔和格蕾丝》的导演。好吧，他是个朋友，你知道的，他导演了《威尔和格蕾丝》的每一集。
That's right. I've listened to his episode, just know he's, yes. So I want to get done with this so we can get to our guest because he's been so kind to wait. So it premieres on June 22nd. It's all in the episodes out every week, or here to week early in Amazon, or the Wondry app. And it's super exciting.
没错。我听过他那一集，就知道他是，是的。所以我想赶快把这事说完，好迎我们的嘉宾，因为他等了太久，太客气了。所以它在6月22日首播。每周都会有新剧集推出，或者可以在亚马逊或Wondry App上提前一周收听。这真的超级令人兴奋。
And it's really, really fun. I'd never seen Watch The Show really after being on it because that my excuse was like, I was there. Like I was there. You didn't watch the one it was on for America? I didn't really. I mean, I remember like bits and pieces, but Eric watched it a little too much. So it's kind of, it's really fun to do the show with them. Anyway, it's just jacking well.
而且真的，真的很有趣。我演完之后其实从来没有真正看这部剧，因为我的借口是，我就在现场。就像我亲历过一样。你在它为美国播出的那会儿没看过？我真的没有。我的意思是，我记得一些零星的片段，但埃里克看得有点太多了。所以和他们一起做这个节目真的很有趣。不管怎样，就是《Just Jack and Will》。
Yeah. Our guest today makes me laugh so much. He's actually born the same year as me, which means he's born the same year as Will. 53 year old man from England. Yes. I consider him British royalty, since he's such a major figure in the comedy world and sci-fi, which as you know, is royalty to me. a major figure in the comedy world, and sci-fi, which as you know is royalty to me. He undoubtedly has both Spielberg and Tom Cruise on Speed Dial. Oh, I know what it is. But it's greatest achievement who is reaching the holy grail of nerd and status.
对。我们今天的嘉宾让我笑得停不下来。他和我同年出生，也就是说他跟威尔同年。一个来自英国的53岁男人。是的。我认为他是英国皇室成员，因为他在喜剧界和科幻界都是重量级人物，而如你所知，这对我来说就是皇室。他在喜剧界和科幻界都是重量级人物，而如你所知，这对我来说就是皇室。他的速拨里绝对有斯皮尔伯格和汤姆·克鲁斯。哦，我知道是谁了。但他最大的成就是达到了极客的圣杯状态。
That's a real thing for the nerd trifecta. As some people call it, this happens when you portrayed prominent characters on Doctor Who, Star Trek, and Star Wars. Guys, it's the brilliant Simon Pegg. I knew it was gonna be Simon. Simon! I knew it was the brilliant Simon Pegg. I knew it was going to be Simon. Simon! I knew it was Simon.
这对于极客三件套来说是真实存在的。正如有些人所说，当你分别在《神秘博士》、《星际迷航》和《星球大战》中饰演重要角色时，就会达成这一点。伙计们，这就是才华横溢的西蒙·佩吉！我早就知道会是西蒙。西蒙！我知道是才华横溢的西蒙·佩吉。我知道会是西蒙。西蒙！我知道是西蒙。
I knew it. I knew it. Well, you didn't have that will. I did. I knew it was Simon. What did you say it? I don't know. It was just, you didn't want to spoil it.
我早就知道了。我早就知道了。好吧，你刚才没说Will。我说了。我知道是西蒙。你刚才说什么了？我不知道。就是，你只是不想剧透。
But isn't it a crazy guy started talking and brought a fact down with those pipes? I thought they were really good. Listen to that. You didn't. No, you didn't. No, you didn't. Simon. I know. Hey, Simon. Hey, man. Great to see you didn't. No, you didn't. No, you didn't. No, you didn't. You didn't voice, Simon.
但这个疯狂的家伙开始说话并用这种嗓音抛出一个梗，难道不是很疯狂吗？我觉得他们真的很好。听听那个。你没有。不，你没有。不，你没有。西蒙。我知道。嘿，西蒙。嘿，老兄，很高兴看到你没有。不，你没有。不，你没有。不，你没有。你没有用真声，西蒙。
I know. I know. Hey, Simon, hey, man, great to see you. Hey, you two, I'm such a fan of this podcast. I feel kind of you're not strange, but you've never. No, I've never met you. Absolutely have. I have.
我知道。我知道。嘿，西蒙，嘿，老兄，很高兴看到你。嘿，你们两个，我是这个播客的超级粉丝。我觉得有点，也不是奇怪，但你们从来没有……不，我从来没见过你。绝对见过。我见过。
Oh, then show them. We've never met, and I just want to say I'm a big show in Heistfield. Well, likewise, I'm massive. By the way, before we get going on all of that, I want to say Simon, I see over your right shoulder spaced, which was the show that you and Edgar did. And I want to talk about space. I loved, as you know, and I've told you, I've embarrassed you before, how much I loved spaced. And for a number of reasons, but walk me through a little because that was your guys first, like a big thing that you all got to you and Edgar and Nick and Nick too. Nick wasn't really an actor before that right? So I mean I remember
哦，那证明一下。我们从来没见过，我只想说我是海斯菲尔德的超级粉丝。好吧，彼此彼此，我是巨大的……顺便说一句，在我们深入聊这些之前，西蒙，我看到你右肩膀后面挂着《屋顶之友》，那是你和埃德加制作的节目。我想聊聊《屋顶之友》。如你所知，我有多爱《屋顶之友》，我以前也对你表达过，甚至让你觉得尴尬，因为我是那么喜欢它。出于很多原因，跟我简单梳理一下，因为那是你们的第一部大制作，你、埃德加、尼克，还有尼克。尼克在那之前其实不是演员，对吧？所以我的意思是，我记得
you telling me this story once years ago. No, he was a waiter. Yeah, and yeah, I moved to London with my girlfriend and she went to work at this Mexican restaurant called Chiquitos. I don't know if you've ever eaten Mexican in London. It's amazing. Um, I don't know for it. She came up from work and stuff. I think it's work. Wacomole started. It actually is where it's invented.
你多年前给我讲过这个故事。不，他是个服务员。对，然后，我和女朋友搬到了伦敦，她去了一家名叫Chiquitos的墨西哥餐厅工作。我不知道你有没有在伦敦吃过墨西哥菜。太棒了。呃，我不知道……她下班回家什么的。我想那是鳄梨酱诞生的工作。实际上就是在那发明的。
Cricklewood. Um, it, he's really funny and he wants to be a stand-up. And I was kind of dabbling with stand-up at the time. And, and we sort of, uh, we met. And, and he was the funniest, is the funniest human being I know. I tried, he tried stand up, it didn't really fit for him, it couldn't convert his hilariousness into a routine. But we came to, we got space and I said, look, come and be in this TV show with me and we can hang out. And he had this character, he'd come up with this sort of this army guy called Mike.
克里克伍德。呃，他真的很有趣，他想成为一名单口喜剧演员。当时我也在尝试单口喜剧。然后，我们，呃，我们遇到了。而且他是，是我认识的最搞笑的人。我试过，他试过单口喜剧，但其实不太适合他，他没法把自己的搞笑转换成一套常规表演。但我们开始做《屋顶之友》时，我说，听着，来和我一起演这个电视剧，我们可以一起闲晃。他当时想出了一个叫迈克的军人角色。
And we wrote it into the show and convinced the producers that he was an actor, which he wasn't. And I think there was another guy called Nick Frost on our sort of equity. So they looked him up and said, yeah, he checks out. And that's how we got into the show and how he started his career. Wow, that's amazing.
我们把它写进了剧里，并说服制片人他是个演员，其实他不是。我想在我们的演员工会名单上还有另一个叫尼克·弗罗斯特的人。所以他们查了一下说，行，没问题。这就是他如何加入这部剧以及他如何开启演艺生涯的。哇，太神奇了。
And then you, what happened with you and Ed girl? Like how did you guys get that show off the ground? We, Jessica, Heinz and I, wrote it. We, Jessica, worked with Edgay before. And he was like the only guy that we could imagine who could sort of make the show. And he came along and we put it together. And he showed us all his storyboards and stuff
然后你，你和埃德加是怎么回事？你们是怎么把那个节目做起来的？我和杰西卡·海恩斯一起写的。我们，杰西卡以前和埃德加合作过。他是我们能想象到的唯一一个能拍出这种节目的人。他来了，我们把项目凑到了一起。他给我们看了他所有的分镜头脚本什么的
and we were kind of just blown away because it's got this incredible vision. And we took it to Channel 4 and they liked... This is a really lucky... We were so lucky, you know, as a time when you could sort of just pitch something and they go, yeah, sure, let's do it. And we were on right after Friends
我们当时简直被惊艳到了，因为他有着令人难以置信的远见。我们把它带到了第四频道，他们很喜欢……这真的很幸运……我们太幸运了，你知道的，那是一个你可以随便抛出一个创意，他们就会说“行，没问题，我们干吧”的年代。我们在《老友记》之后播出
and it was this strange sort of, slightly surreal show, but it really found its audience. And that was where the idea for Sean kind of came about and where our sort of relationship began. So yeah, that was the beginnings of it all. Do you know the number of things that you and Nick and Edgar have done together? I could probably count them, but it might be boring for the podcast.
这是一个奇怪的、略带超现实色彩的节目，但它确实找到了它的观众。肖恩（Sean）这个名字的灵感就是从那里来的，我们的合作关系也是从那里开始的。所以，是的，这是一切的开端。你知道你、尼克和埃德加一起合作过多少部作品吗？我大概能数得过来，但对播客来说可能有点无聊。
I don't know, let's go for one. It doesn't. Two. Probably what we did to space, then the three corner to films, and then we did Tintin. Tintin. Yeah, like five or six, I guess. And we've done other stuff as well.
不知道，我们说一个试试。不是。两个。大概是《屋顶之友》，然后是“血与冰淇淋”三部曲，然后我们拍了《丁丁历险记》。《丁丁历险记》。对，大概五六个吧。我们还做过其他东西。
I wanted to ask you about, because like, you know, your credits, you know, like talk about fandom. I'm like a creepy stalker fan of yours because you're in everything I love, right? So I, you're like the fandom you're associated with by default. How often do you check? Because you're not on social media, like you're not on anything. How often do you check in to see what's being said if anything or do you avoid the internet? Because you, you know Because you have those iconic stories that you constantly tell from everything you're working on,
我想问你的是，因为你知道，你的作品，你知道，谈到粉丝文化。我是你疯狂的跟踪狂粉丝，因为你参演了我喜欢的一切，对吧？所以，你就像是默认与粉丝文化绑定在一起。你多久查看一次？因为你不上社交媒体，你什么都不上。你多久查看一次网上在说什么（如果有的话），还是你刻意避开互联网？因为你，你知道的
but you have no outlet to put them. So people must just be like, you know, salivated. What have got an Instagram now? Are you do? And I follow, I follow SmartLess. That's more like, Oh, you guys. What?
因为你总是有那些不断讲述的关于你参与过的所有项目的经典故事，
Yeah. What a great, I was kind of upset when I said, What are we saying? Oh, we'll follow your back. What have we been saying on there? Yeah, I was kind of upset when I said, what are we saying? Oh, follow your pack. What have we been saying on there? Yeah, whatever. Terrific. But do you ever look at what people are saying or do you not, you're like, I can't, I don't
但你没有地方可以倾诉。所以人们一定都在垂涎三尺。我现在有一个Instagram了？你真的有？我关注了，我关注了SmartLess。更像是，哦，你们这帮人。什么？
care, I'm not. Sometimes, I was on Twitter for a while and then I left that because it just felt like, it just felt like a party where everybody was drunk and angry. Yeah. Yeah. I sort of checked out of that. I've kept the account just for sort of info. Twitter's like my house growing up just drunk and angry. Yeah.
对。多么棒的……我刚才说“我们在说什么？”的时候还有点心烦。哦，我们会回关你的。我们在上面都说过什么？对，随便吧。太棒了。但你从来不看别人在说什么吗？还是你觉得，我才不
I remember you and Nick, and the reason I got, the person who showed me who actually set up my Twitter account, physically did it on my phone with Pete Seraphine, which, I was a Pete. Yeah. And we were in Vancouver. And I kept and I was arguing against it. It's like 2009. Yeah, 2009 or 10. What month? What month? It was actually. No, no, Simon, he knows this stuff. It's crazy. No, it's no joke. I'm not joking. Just give him two seconds. He'll drop it. It was February 2010. It probably was.'ll drop you. It was February 2010. That's crazy.
在乎，我不会。有时候会，我以前用过一段时间推特，后来不玩了，因为感觉就像一个所有人喝醉了又在生气的派对。对。对。我就不怎么看了。我保留这个账号只是为了获取资讯。推特就像我小时候长大的房子，充满了醉酒和愤怒。对。
It probably was. It probably was. It just inverts me every time. Simon, did you, so you're born in 1970 on Valentine's Day before I get into all your career stuff because I can't wait. Do you have any crazy story about hooking up on Valentine's Day, which is your birthday, and it's turning into something? If it's a bad date, say it for our sister podcast, bad dates. No, I spoke to Jimi LeRubat doing that,
我记得你和尼克，我用推特的原因——帮我注册推特账号的人，亲手在我的手机上操作的那个人，是皮特·塞拉菲诺维奇，我当时是皮特的粉丝。对。我们在温哥华。我一直，我当时还在抗拒。那是2009年。对，2009年或10年。几月？几月？其实是。不，不，西蒙，他知道这些。太疯狂了。不，这不是开玩笑。我没开玩笑。给他两秒钟。他就能说出来。是2010年2月。可能吧。他能说出来。是2010年2月。太疯狂了。
but I don't have any bad dates, really. I don't like it. I think of anything that would make the podcast fun. It's the mailman who delivers my birthday cards thinks I'm a stud, obviously, but otherwise, you know, you get it, really. That's hysterical. All right, so you were born.
可能吧。绝对是。每次都让我惊叹不已。西蒙，你是在1970年情人节出生的，在我聊你的演艺生涯之前——因为我迫不及待了。你有没有什么关于在情人节（也就是你的生日）约会并发展出什么故事的疯狂经历？如果是个糟糕的约会，留给我们的姐妹播客《Bad Dates》讲吧。不，我跟杰米拉聊过这个，
I thought bad dates was more about like December 7th, 1941. She was. That's so stupid. That is so dumb. That was a terrible date. Wait, so, okay. So you were born Simon Beckenham, but why did I tell me about that? Well, my mum remarried.
但我其实没有什么糟糕的约会。我不喜欢那样。如果要说有什么能让播客变有趣的话，那就是给我送信的邮递员显然觉得我是个万人迷，除此之外，你知道的，也就那样了。太搞笑了。好吧，所以你是出生于……
My parents splits up. My dad, I kept in touch with Well, my mom remarried. My parents split up. My dad, I kept in touch with my dad, as which was good. There's a, I'm sorry to gloat, Sean. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. See, I do listen to the folk, I guess. Simon, I think your dad just had a slower car.
我以为《Bad Dates》更多是关于1941年12月7日这种日子。她是的。太蠢了。真是笨死了。那是个糟糕的日子。等等，好吧。所以你出生时叫西蒙·贝金汉姆，但为什么……跟我讲讲这个。好吧，我妈妈改嫁了。
That was a lot. Yeah. By the way, if your dad runs into my dad, let me know. They're good friends. Yeah. When my mom remarried, I remember I was seven and I remember thinking I don't want to have a different name to my mom.
我父母离婚了。我爸爸，我和我爸保持着联系。好吧，我妈妈改嫁了。我父母离婚了。我爸爸，我和我爸保持着联系，这挺好的。抱歉，肖恩，我有点幸灾乐祸。对不起。对不起。看吧，我确实听这个节目，我想。西蒙，我觉得你爸只是开了一辆比较慢的车。
And she married Richard Pegg. And I just made that decision. I thought I want to have the same name as my mom. I don't want to come into my school and then to say, hello Mrs. Beckingham and her have to correct the teacher. I remember making that little calculation when I was a kid, which is strangely adult.
那挺多的。顺便说一句，如果你爸碰巧遇到了我爸，告诉我一声。他们是好朋友。对。我妈改嫁时，我记得我7岁，我当时想，我不想跟我妈拥有不同的姓氏。
Will, do you have a shunt? Sean, why was gonna say that? Sean, didn't you one time say on the podcast, hey, to anybody out there, if you happen to run into my dad, make sure to reverse and run into him again. Totally. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Whoa.
她嫁给了理查德·佩格。我当时就作出了那个决定。我想跟我妈拥有相同的姓氏。我不想去学校然后老师说“贝金汉姆太太你好”，而她不得不纠正老师。我记得我小时候做过这种小心思的盘算，现在想来出奇地像个大人。
By the way, we were gonna talk about this a while ago. It's total sidebar. Sure. My dad showed up to Good Night a while ago. It's total sidebar. Sure. My dad showed up to Good Night Oscar in Chicago. What? Yeah. I knew that. Crazy.
威尔，你有个尚？肖恩，我刚才正要说这个。肖恩，你有没有一次在播客里说，嘿，外面的任何人，如果你碰巧遇到我爸，一定要倒车再轧他一次。完全有。哈哈哈哈哈。哇。
But he didn't come backstage during that. I didn't see him. Well, I guess he didn't like the show. He'd probably hate it. That's very strange. No, isn't that what you're supposed to infer? No, and then he showed up on my sister's Facebook and said, I love the show. Yeah, but he said something weird.
顺便说一句，我们刚才就想聊这个来着。这完全是个题外话。当然。我爸前不久去芝加哥看了《晚安，奥斯卡》。什么？对。我知道这事。太疯狂了。
He said something like an Oscar Levant, just like I remembered him. But no, like that's my son. Oh, so he was like humble bragging. No, my son just like I remembered him. That's my son. He's got a clear memory of Oscar Levant, but he does of you. He doesn't remember you waving from the window. Yeah.
但他后台没来找我。我没看到他。好吧，我猜他不喜欢这个节目。他大概恨透了。这太奇怪了。不，这难道不是你该推导出来的吗？不，然后他在我姐姐的Facebook上留言说：“我喜欢这个节目。”对，但他说了句很怪的话。
You should show up to his house as Oscar Levant. You go. How have you been? Oh my God. It's really funny. Okay, so, but wait, this is what's so cool. I love this. I did this exact same thing as you Simon.
他说：“奥斯卡·莱万特，跟我记忆中的一模一样。”但不是说“那是我的儿子”。哦，所以他在花式凡尔赛。不，“我儿子跟我记忆中的一模一样。那是我的儿子。”他对奥斯卡·莱万特的记忆倒是很清晰，对你却没有。他不记得你在窗户挥手了。对。
So, you started acting at like 16. You went to Strafford upon Avan, but you just study English literature and theater. But as a boy, you would listen to John Williams' scores. And I used to listen to him all the time, and so did my husband, Scotty, I'm obsessed. Yeah. He's the greatest. It was one of my most sort of, my priortist moments, I think, ever in my career, with Tintin was seeing my name come up on the screen and then music by John Williams. Yeah, that's insane. Yeah, that's insane. You know, because for me, it was, I used to listen to it
你应该扮成奥斯卡·莱万特去他家。然后说：“你最近怎么样？”哦天哪。真的太搞笑了。好吧，所以，但等等，最酷的是这个。我太喜欢了。我跟你做过一模一样的事，西蒙。
and imagine myself in movies and it was the soundtrack to my childhood, you know, I loved him. I still do, he's the most incredible component. We go, Skydien, I go every year to Hollywood Bowl to watch him conduct with the lightsabers. Did you ever been there? It's insane. Oh, I wish I had.
所以，你16岁左右开始演戏。你去了埃文河畔斯特拉福德，但你只学了英国文学和戏剧。但作为一个小男孩，你会听约翰·威廉姆斯的电影配乐。我以前经常听，我的丈夫斯科蒂也一样，我简直着迷了。对。他是最伟大的。这可以说是我的职业生涯中，我认为最自豪的时刻之一，在拍《丁丁历险记》时，看到我的名字出现在银幕上，紧接着音乐就是约翰·威廉姆斯的。对，这太疯狂了。对，这太疯狂了。你知道的，因为对我来说，我以前经常听
Oh, you got to come. You got to kind of alienate to Jason. Oh, fuck, man come. You got to just kind of alienate Jason. Oh, fuck man. Inverted again. You know, John Williams plays a few holes a golf every day at four o'clock. Still? He's 19.
然后想象自己身处电影中，那是我的童年配乐，你知道的，我爱惨了他。我至今仍然爱着，他最不可思议的作曲家。我和斯科蒂每年都会去好莱坞露天剧场看他指挥，手里挥舞着光剑。你去过那里吗？太疯狂了。哦，我希望我去过。
Yeah. Yeah. He drives down the hill and his golf cart and he hits it a few times and that's his routine. And he said, we saw him about two weeks ago and just out of, barely, he just barely ever say, if you see Sean Sean Hayes tell me that asshole. That's interesting. That's interesting. We weren't sure, but we were pretty sure that's what it was.
哦，你得来。你得来疏远一下杰森。哦，操，老兄，来吧。你得去疏远一下杰森。哦，操，老兄。又被反转了。你知道，约翰·威廉姆斯每天下午四点还要打几个洞的高尔夫。现在还在打？他19岁了。
Yeah. Stop nerding out of my music. Sounds like a fucking loser. Stop fucking mentioning it. Stop identifying his entire fucking life face of my fucking music to my movies and get a fucking life and have some real life experiences. Other than talking about fucking nerd movies. Wow, you had a lot to say.
对。对。他开着高尔夫球车顺着山坡下去，击几次球，这就是他的日常。他说，我们大约两周前看到他，几乎是出于……他几乎从来不说，如果你看到肖恩·海斯，告诉他他是个混蛋。这很有趣。这很有趣。我们不太确定，但我们相当确定他就是这个意思。
Was that in between the whole? That's all I caught. He kept going. We've Simon, what do you have a favorite John Williams score? The Impost drives back. Oh yes, of course. Without a favorite John Williams score? The Empire Strikes Back. Oh, yes, of course. Without a doubt. That's more favorite.
别再对着我的音乐犯极客了。听起来像个他妈的失败者。别他妈再提了。别把你他妈的整个人生都跟我的音乐和电影绑在一起，去过他妈的生活，去体验点真实的人生吧。除了谈论那些他妈的极客电影。哇，你话真多。
I love that. Is that held up as one of the all-time greats in that sort of, in the John Williams canon? I think so. I mean, you know, it's just, it's got so many sort of classic themes on it. And, you know, it's the first time we had the Imperial March and and and and and and and all these sort of incredible. It's just a beautiful, beautiful school. Yeah, that's pretty much mutually agreed that that's the best
那是夹在中间的整段吗？我只捕捉到了这些。他一直在说。西蒙，你最喜欢约翰·威廉姆斯的哪部配乐？《帝国反击战》。哦，对，当然。毫无疑问的最爱。
of the Star Wars movies, right? Absolutely. I think so. And they're really in what nine? I can't remember nine. It's just been a lot. Well, 77 it was 80. Like we were finally doing I and will were like 10 or 11.
我太喜欢了。这在约翰·威廉姆斯的经典作品中被公认为是有史以来最伟大的作品之一吗？我想是的。我的意思是，你知道的，它有太多那种经典的旋律了。而且，你知道，这是我们第一次听到《帝国进行曲》以及所有这些不可思议的音乐。这简直是一部美丽至极的配乐。对，大家基本都默认那是最好的
Can I just say this? Can I just say I hope they make nine more. You know what? I probably they probably will. They are. They are. I saw the first one in 1977. And if we've talked about this with somebody,
《星球大战》电影，对吧？绝对的。我也这么觉得。它们拍到第九部了吧？我不记得是不是九部了。总之有很多。好吧，77年那部是80年……我们当时年纪还小，我和威尔大概10岁或11岁。
I saw the first the first one four times in the theater. It's the only time I've ever seen. And then and then I start because you know, I got older. Um, hey, so... So, let me just... Okay, so I mean, I want to go back, hang on, I'd do one... One turn date? I turned date. And once I turned date, I was like,
我能说这个吗？我只想说我希望他们再拍九部。你知道吗？他们可能真的会拍。他们正在拍。他们正在拍。我1977年看了第一部。如果我们跟谁聊过这个，
what am I fucking doing? I'll never get laid. Oh, my God. And we will be right back. Smartless. Get support from Viori clothing. Tired of sacrificing style for comfort or vice versa? Look no further than Viori.
我把第一部在电影院看了四遍。这是我唯一一次这样看。然后，然后我开始，因为你知道，我长大了。嗯，所以……所以，等一下，好吧，所以我的意思是，等等，我想转个……转个话题？转到约会。一旦我转到约会，我就在想，
The performance clothing brand that combines both. Viori offers the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet y'all, making it the perfect investment in your happiness. From joggers to leggings to crew next, beauty has everything you need to stay comfy and stylish, no matter what you're doing. For instance, me, here, talking into a microphone, I'm sitting on a couch, it's not incredibly comfortable.
我他妈在干什么？我永远也别想约会了。哦，天哪。我们马上回来。SmartLess。获取Viori服装的支持。厌倦了为了舒适而牺牲时尚，反之亦然？那就来看看Viori吧。
I need clothes that are more comfortable than the couch I'm sitting on. And with Viori, I've got that. I'm going to Viori Cloud right now. You know, for listeners, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com-smartless. That's V-U-O-R-I-.com- slash smart list. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any US orders over $75 and free returns. Go to
这个兼具两者优势的运动服装品牌。Viori提供地球上最舒适、最多功能的服装，伙计们，绝对是你对幸福的最佳投资。从慢跑裤、打底裤到圆领衫，Viori应有尽有，让你无论在做什么都能保持舒适和时尚。比如我，坐在这里对着话筒，我坐在沙发上，其实并不是特别舒服。
Viori.com slash smart list and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. Ciao. Glow Thing. Ciao. for in the morning with all the lights off, trying not to wake up your roommates, or the recommendations that you share with your friends on the top six comedy podcasts that are the best to listen to on your way to the gym and back, or even your new haircut, which may or may not be an epic bull cut from the 90s. And hopefully it is.
我需要的衣服要比我坐的沙发更舒服。有了Viori，我做到了。我马上要打开Viori网站了。你知道的，对于听众朋友，他们提供首单8折优惠。快去Viori.com-smartless购买地球上最舒适、最多功能的服装吧。网址是V-U-O-R-I点com斜杠smart list。你不仅能享受首单8折，所有美国境内超过75美元的订单还能享受免费配送和免费退货。快去
Everything that makes you, you makes all the difference. State Farm believes insurance should work the same way. Now hear me out here. Your plan, your coverage selections can be personalized by you. And the ability to choose the plan you want by picking the options that fit you. Like choosing to bundle your home and auto policies is what the State Farm Personal Price Plan is all about. Getting the coverage you want at an affordable price just for you.
Viori.com斜杠smart list，探索Viori服装的百搭魅力吧。再见。发光物。再见。早上灯全关着，尽量不吵醒室友，或者是你在去健身房的路上和回家途中向朋友推荐的那六个最适合听的喜剧播客，甚至是你那可能很潮也可能是一场90年代锅盖头灾难的新发型。但愿是个好发型。
So are you ready to make things personal? I bet you are. Call or go to statefarm.com today to create your State Farm Personal Price Plan. Prices vary by state, options selected by customer, availability and eligibility may vary. That's all. I'm not afraid to tell you, we get support from Audible, okay? It's the home of storytelling. Now, I'm not, you know, a great reader, okay? I've for a bunch of reasons that I'm not going to bore you with.
造就独一无二的你的，正是这些点点滴滴。State Farm坚信保险也该如此。听我细细道来。你的方案、你的险种选择都可以由你个性化定制。你可以通过挑选适合自己的选项来选择你想要的方案。比如将你的房屋和汽车保险打包组合，这就是State Farm个性化价格方案的全部意义所在。以实惠的价格为你量身定制你想要的保障。
But so this audible these these people they they're on to something here. All right, I may not read, but I will listen. Now, you're going to discover thousands of podcasts from popular favorites to exclusive new series. You're going to you're going to find guided wellness programs with audible. You're going to find theatrical performances is comedy and exclusive audible originals from top celebrities renowned experts and exciting new voices in audio. The Audible app makes it easy to listen anytime, anywhere while you're traveling, working out, walking, doing chores, you decide. All right? Now, for instance, this book, the Suttler Art of Not Giving A Fuck by Mark Manson, this is a potential key to life.
所以，准备好开启个性化体验了吗？我猜你已经准备好了。今天就致电或访问statefarm.com，创建你的State Farm个性化价格方案。价格因州而异，以客户选择的选项为准，可用性和资格可能会有所不同。好了。我毫不掩饰地告诉你，我们得到了Audible的支持！它是故事的发源地。现在，我可不是什么伟大的阅读者，好吧？因为种种原因，我就不拿这些无聊的事烦你了。
It is, you know, they talk about on the show, the sexy indifference is a obnoxious term, but it's better said by Mark Manson here or better heard on Audible. New members can try Audible for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days audible.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. Simon, I remember before we met, which was many, many, many moons ago, if you remember, I picked you up somewhere, and you were staying at Lermitage, and we went over there and had the best time. That's right.
但Audible这些人，他们确实有一套。好吧，我可能不读书，但我会听。现在，你将发现数以千计的播客，从热门最爱到独家新系列。你将在Audible上找到引导式健康计划。你将找到戏剧表演、喜剧以及来自顶级名人、知名专家和音频领域激动人心的新声音的独家Audible原创作品。Audible应用程序让你无论旅行、健身、散步还是做家务，随时随地都能轻松收听，由你决定。好了。现在，比如这本书，马克·曼森的《掌控习惯》（The Subtle Art of Not Giving a F*ck），这可能是人生的关键。
The first time we hung out. I remember, I was, you know, because I'd seen Edgar had told me about rest of the development. And I'd resisted it for a while. I kind of didn't know what to do. I was like, I was know, because I'd seen Edgar had told me about arrest development and I'd resisted it for a while. You know when you're saying sort of in comedy and I know you resisted it forever Sean, but I was like, you know you kind of resent stuff when you told it's good. Yeah, oh yeah, you've got to see this show, it's incredible.
节目里也讨论过，“性感冷漠”是个讨厌的词，但由这里的马克·曼森说出来，或者在Audible上听起来会更好。新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。访问audible.com斜杠smartless，或发送短信smartless到500-500。网址是audible.com斜杠smartless，或发送短信smartless到500-500，即可免费试用Audible 30天。audible.com斜杠smartless。节目继续。西蒙，我记得在我们见面之前——那是好久好久以前了，如果你还记得的话，我曾在某处接上你，你当时住在埃米塔日酒店，我们过去玩得超级开心。没错。
And I'll give it a look and I'd sort of didn't. Yeah, I've got to see this show, it's incredible. And I'll give it a look, and I didn't. I've done those. Eventually, I begrudgingly watched it. And I just sort of, you know, sometimes, as a funny person, you watch comedy, like somebody watching a physics lecture, you just sort of be not. Waiting to know I like it. Yeah.
那是我们第一次一起玩。我记得，我当时，你知道的，因为我看到埃德加跟我提起过《发展受阻》。我抗拒了一段时间。我当时有点不知道该怎么办。我当时想，你知道的，因为我看到埃德加跟我提起过《发展受阻》，我抗拒了一段时间。你知道那种你在喜剧界，我知道你抗拒了很久，肖恩，但我当时想，当别人告诉你某个东西很好时，你多少会有点逆反心理。对，哦，对，你会觉得“你得看看这个节目，太不可思议了”。
This is it. This is it. Why the fuck do anything ever again? This is too fucking good. Jason and I at one of our Sunday dinners sat down and pretty much almost all the same things neither Jason and I have seen it. It's like a list that we both made. It's not because I don't want to know if you overwhelmed it to get started. Well, sometimes it feels like homework, which is, which is a bummer. It comes to the slight pressure, doesn't it?
然后我会去看一眼，结果没有。哦，“你得看看这个节目，太不可思议了”。然后我会去看一眼，结果没有。我干过这种事。最终，我还是勉强看了。然后我只是觉得，你知道的，有时作为喜剧演员，你看喜剧，就像一个人在看物理讲座，你只会点头。等着吧，我知道我会喜欢。对。
It does come with pressure. And then because yeah, and you have shows that are really good that are mutual. Friends have done and you're like, fuck, I should watch it. Everybody says it's great. And part of me was like, I don't want to watch it also. I don't want to have an opinion in case I run into them. It's like, it's like I want to see somebody on Broadway. And then after the show, you got to go up and you got to be like, yeah, you were great. Sean, like whatever, just for lack of another, whatever, whatever you got to say, whatever the name of the person is, you've got. But wait, Simon, Sean was in, by the way, if you're in New York, go see it, I'm not joking. I have to say, I'm going to be, I'd love to come, Sean. Honestly, I'm going
就是这个。就是这个。为什么还要他妈的再创作任何东西？这太他妈棒了。杰森和我在我们的一个周日晚宴上坐下来，几乎看完了所有东西，杰森和我以前都没看。就像是我们俩列的一张清单。这不是因为我不想知道你是不是因为太火爆才开始看的。好吧，有时它感觉像家庭作业，这挺扫兴的。这确实伴随着一点压力，不是吗？
to be there with mission in, in July. Oh, great. Come on. He's incredible. Yeah, it's sweet. But Simon, we first met and I had just seen Sean of the dead. And that movie for me stands out. And I've watched it recently with my kids and it's, and it's holds up because it's legitimately great and fun to see with the kids. Yeah, and I found it so inspiring at that time. I felt like you guys were doing something that not a lot of other people were doing. You were, it was smart and it was silly
确实有压力。然后因为，是的，你有一些朋友拍的真的很棒的剧，你会想，操，我真该看看。每个人都说好。我的一部分心里活动是，我不想看，我也不想发表意见，万一我碰巧遇到他们。就像，就像你想去看百老汇演出。然后演出结束后，你得走过去说，嘿，你演得太棒了。肖恩，不管怎样，随便换个什么名字，随便你得说点什么。但等等，西蒙，肖恩参演了——顺便说一句，如果你在纽约，去看吧，我不是开玩笑。我必须得说，我要去，我很想去，肖恩。老实说，我七月份带着《碟中谍》要去那儿。哦，太棒了。来吧。他太不可思议了。对，太好了。但西蒙，我们第一次见面时，我刚看完《僵尸肖恩》。那部电影对我来说非常突出。我最近和孩子们一起重温了它，而且，它经受住了时间的考验，因为它是部名副其实的伟大电影，和孩子们一起看非常有趣。对，我当时觉得它太鼓舞人心了。我觉得你们在做一件当时很多人都没在做的事。你们，它既聪明又愚蠢，
and it was, and it was really tight. Whenever I saw, right, whenever I saw you will, whenever that movie came out, it's all you talked about to me, all the time. I feel, for real. For real, I still hold it up is such a great Every moment of it the writing is really good. It's really well shot. It's really well directed It's really incredibly acted like every single moment of it man
而且非常紧凑。每当我看到——对，每当我看到你，威尔，每当那部电影上映时，你跟我谈论的全是它，随时随地。说真的。说真的，我至今仍然把它奉为一部如此伟大的作品。它的每一个瞬间，剧本都非常棒。镜头拍得极好。导演极好。演技也极其出色，每一个瞬间都是如此，老兄。
And that must have been such a huge turning point for you for Sean of the dead Yeah, well, I was absolutely was because it you know, we got some Some sort of exposure over there, and a lot of cool kind of directors came into back for our go, and we managed to get a theatrical release over there, thanks to, I think it was thanks to ANTIKAL NEWS, Harry Nolz's website. Oh, wow. And so, yeah, and so coming over, and not to bat it back to you guys,
那对你来说一定是一个巨大的转折点，《僵尸肖恩》？对，绝对是的，因为它，你知道的，我们在那边获得了一些曝光度，很多很酷的导演开始支持我们的项目，我们设法在那边获得了院线发行，多亏了，我想多亏了Ain't It Cool News，哈里·诺尔斯的网站。哦，哇。所以，是的，来到这里，并不是想把话头抛回给你们，
but I kind of felt the same thing about arrested. You know, it was like, these guys, we all say, Nick and I always say, people know something. If you see someone who gets it, who is kind of, you feel like they're the same kind of person as you, you say, hey, they know something. And it was, you guys were just doing something that was just so that and, and it was, it was inspirational. And I always, and also, sure, not to leave you
但我对《发展受阻》有着同样的感受。你知道，就像是，这些家伙——我们都这么说，尼克和我都总是说，人们懂行。如果你看到某个人懂行，他们跟你是一类人，你就会说，嘿，他们懂。而你们，你们当时做的东西就是那么棒，而且非常鼓舞人心。而且我一直，还有，肖恩，不是故意漏掉你，我一直觉得在看《威尔和格蕾丝》时，因为你总是，你知道的——虽然没有太过分，但我一直觉得你绝对偷走了那部剧的风头。我当时就想，我敢肯定他懂行，因为《威尔和格蕾丝》是一部很大的，你知道的，它是一部电视网喜剧。体量巨大。你知道的，它不是那种另类的东西，尽管它是一部极其先锋的节目。然后你突然出现在《波特兰迪亚》或者别的什么节目里，我就想，耶，我早就知道了。我就知道。对，我很喜欢那个节目。顺便说一句，他太搞笑了。你这么说太对了，肖恩，你确实一直都在抢戏。
out, I always thought on watching Will and Grace, because you always kind of, you know, not too much, but you all stole that show, I thought, for sure. And I always thought, I'm sure he knows something, because Will and Grace is a big, you know, it was, it was a network, common, it a big, you know, it was a network comedy. It was massive. You know, it wasn't sort of an alternative kind of thing, even though it was an incredibly progressive show. And then you popped up on like Port Landeer or something and I was like, yes, I knew it. I knew you said. Yeah, I love that show. By the way, he's so funny. You say that and it's so true, Sean, you did steal that show all the time.
出来了，我一直觉得在看《威尔和格蕾丝》的时候，因为你总是那种，你知道的，虽然不是太多，但你们俩确实抢尽了那部剧的风头，我当时就这么觉得。我一直觉得，我敢肯定他知道些什么，因为《威尔和格蕾丝》是一部很大的，你知道的，它是一部，它是一部电视网的喜剧。它太火了。你知道的，它可不是那种另类的节目，尽管它是一部极其前卫的节目。然后你突然出现在像《波特兰迪亚》这样的节目里，当时我就想，太对了，我早就知道了。我早就知道你说的。是的，我很喜欢那个节目。顺便说一句，他太搞笑了。你这么说太对了，肖恩，你确实一直都在抢那部剧的风头。
Well, amongst a bunch of scene dealers, you were a scenes dealer. I remember Nick has one of those, I hold Nick is one of those guys. He's so naturally frosty, so naturally funny. And just for really quick, for Tracy, Nick Frost is a comedian actor. He collabries, hot fuzz, brawl, the world's end, your bestie. Hot fuzz, my the worlds and your bestie. Hot Fuzz, my God, you're a great movie. Hot Fuzz. And we were, once I'm standing outside this restaurant in LA and I was having a cigarette
74|||嗯，在一群搞场景的行家里头，你绝对是个个中翘楚。我记得尼克就是那种人，我觉得尼克就是那种人。他天生就带着一种冷冰冰的幽默感，天生就搞笑。顺便跟特蕾西解释一下，尼克·弗罗斯特是个喜剧演员。他合作过的有《热血警探》、《僵尸肖恩》、《世界尽头》，是你的死党。《热血警探》，我的天呐，世界尽头，还有你的死党。《热血警探》，天呐，真是部好电影。《热血警探》。我们当时，有一次我站在洛杉矶一家餐厅外面抽烟
with Nick and there were these two like really douchey guys. I don't know if this story will translate standing right there. And we, as we walked, they were just having the worst conversation, LA conversation. As we went inside, Nick goes, all right, talk to you later to the audience. Complete strangers. I didn't even know them. We hadn't talked a little bit at all. And as he's opening the door, he just looked at them and went, all right, talk to you later. To the other, it's completely strange. I didn't even know them. We hadn't talked a little bit at all. And as he's opening the door, he just looked at the window and I talked to him.
和尼克在一起，旁边有两个超级装的人。我不知道这个故事翻译过来是不是那个味儿。当时他们就在旁边，聊着最让人无语的天，典型的洛杉矶对话。等我们往里走的时候，尼克突然来了一句：“行吧，回头发信息联系。”对象是完全不认识的陌生人。我们根本不认识他们。之前一点也没说过话。就在他推门的时候，他看着他们就来了句：“行吧，回头发信息联系。”对象是完全不认识的陌生人。我们根本不认识他们。之前一点也没说过话。就在他推门的时候，他看着窗户那边就跟人说回头发信息。
It was so funny. Fuck me. And it just, it was so naturally funny. And it made me laugh like driving home. It made me laugh like a kid thinking about it. Will you love that dry sense of humor, that British sense of humor? Was there, was there a lot of that up in Toronto at being, you know, British colony at one point like maybe, I was always
太搞笑了。真他妈绝了。而且就，太自然好笑了。把我都逗笑了，开车回家的路上还在笑，像个小孩一样一想起来就想笑。你们是不是都很喜欢那种冷面幽默、那种英式幽默？那在多伦多那边，因为曾经是英国殖民地什么的，会不会也有很多这种幽默？我一直都是
a fan. I know I've been accused of being an angle file for many years and I do, I do enjoy. I just think that there's something to, you know, when I was 17, I saw with nail and I the first time. And I was like, this, this is the kind of shit I like. And I don't know, it's always just seem smarter. And again, I know so many funny, smart, amazing American. But the style of that just never asks for a laugh. No, you know, it makes you, yeah. You just go right.
他的粉丝。我知道我多年来一直被指控为哈英族，我的确、我的确挺喜欢。我只是觉得有些东西，你知道的，我17岁第一次看《我与长指甲》的时候。我就觉得，这、这正是我喜欢的调调。而且不知道为什么，这总是显得更聪明一些。话说回来，我也认识好多超级幽默、聪明、了不起的美国人。但那种英式风格就是从来不刻意求笑。对吧，你懂的，它会让你，对。你会直接会心一笑。
I heard you once described your Nick's relationship to my fair lady or something, like, what's the comparison? What is that? Yeah, he was like this kind of rough around the edges, Oike, and I was this university graduate who'd moved to London from Bristol and found him in an Mexican restaurant and taught him in the ways of, you know, high culture.
我听你以前形容过你和尼克的关系统，就像《窈窕淑女》什么的，怎么个对比法？那是怎么回事？对，他就像那种有点粗犷的粗人，而我则是那种从布里斯托搬到伦敦的大学毕业生，在一家墨西哥餐厅发现了这个宝藏，然后教导他各种，你知道的，高雅文化。
Very, very. Sure. I mean, Nick was, you know, high culture. Very, very... Sure, I mean, Nick was, you know, he was like... He was, he would be the first to say he was like a little thug, but he was just so gifted, so funny, in a way that still to this day he makes me laugh. Like, you know, when I listen to you guys, it reminds me of my relationship with Nick and Edgar just because it just runs on laughter
非常、非常……当然，我是说，尼克是那种，高雅文化。非常、非常……当然，我是说，尼克是，你知道的，他就像……他，他会是第一个承认自己曾经像个小混混的人，但他就是那么有天赋，那么搞笑，直到今天他依然能把我逗乐。就像，你知道的，当我听你们几个聊天时，这让我想起了我和尼克、埃德加的关系，因为我们的相处就是充满了笑声
and it never gets tiring or boring. It's constantly hilariously funny. Well, and respect, like mass every spec. Yeah, we had a big dinner years ago. By the way, you're gonna fucking freak out when I tell you this, you guys are gonna be so bummed out because I think it was November 2005. And I mean, I can't.
而且永远不会觉得累或者无聊。随时随地都爆笑连连。还有尊重，绝对的相互尊重。对，我们几年前吃过一顿大餐。顺便说一句，我跟你说这个的时候你俩绝对会惊掉下巴，你们俩肯定会郁闷死，因为我觉得那是2005年11月。而且我是说，我记不清了。
In London. And we had that big dinner with a bunch of us Simon. And it was me and Amy and you guys and Darren Brown, the magician. Yes. Did you remember that? Yeah, of course. Yes, long time ago. And I think, did I tell this story about who,
在伦敦。我们一大群人跟西蒙一起吃了那顿大餐。当时有我和艾米，还有你们几个，以及魔术师达伦·布朗。没错。你还记得吗？对，当然记得。没错，好久以前了。然后我想，我是不是讲过这个故事，关于谁，
about saying whether or not you could be hypnotized? Did I tell this hip and tell? No. So we were at this big dinner and Simon and, I guess, Darren wanted to come. He was a fan of arrest development because he liked, he's a magician or whatever. And there were a bunch of guys there.
关于讨论你到底能不能被催眠？我讲过这个催眠的故事吗？没有。所以我们当时在一场大餐上，西蒙还有，我猜达伦也想来。他是《发展受阻》的粉丝，因为他喜欢，他是个魔术师什么的。当时还有一堆人在场。
Who else is there? He wanted to meet an illusionist. Yeah, he did. Joe Cornish, I think, was there. A bunch of them. And Pete and I asked around the table, I said to Darren Brown, the hypnotist, his magician, whatever I said, can you tell if somebody's really susceptible to being hypnotized and being persuaded?
还有谁在场？他想见见幻觉魔术师。对，他确实想。乔·考尼什好像也在。还有好几个。然后皮特和我环顾了一下桌子，我对催眠师、魔术师达伦·布朗说，不管怎样，我问他：“你能看出谁特别容易被催眠和被说服吗？”
And as we went around, I said, everybody go around the table and say whether or not you think you, because he sort of said, yeah, I can kind of tell. And so everybody went around the table and I remember I said, we went around, I said, everybody go around the table and say whether or not you think you, because he sort of said, yeah, I can kind of tell. And so everybody went around the table and I remember I said, like, I definitely could be persuaded to do probably anything. We ran around, I never had different answers. But I remember Amy Polar at the time going, there's no way, you can't get me. Just in that very Amy way, it's like, no way, there's no way, very Boston, like, no way, no fucking way. You can't get me just in that very Amy way. It's like no way. There's no way very Boston like no way no fucking way You can't persuade me anything
然后我们轮流发言，我对大家说，每个人都在桌上说说看你觉得自己，因为他之前说过，是的，我差不多能看出来。所以每个人都在桌上表态了，我记得我说过，我们转了一圈，我说，每个人都在桌上说说看你觉得自己，因为他之前说过，是的，我差不多能看出来。所以每个人都在桌上表态了，我记得我说过，就像，我绝对是可以被说服去做任何事的类型。我们一圈转下来，大家的答案各不相同。但我记得当时的艾米·波勒说：“绝对不可能，你休想催眠我。”就是那种典型的艾米式语气，就像是“不可能，绝对不可能”，非常波士顿腔，就像“没门，他妈的绝对没门。你休想催眠我”，就是那种非常艾米的语气。就像“没门，绝对没门”，非常波士顿腔，像“没门，他妈的绝对没门。你休想说服我做任何事”
And we're at this really fancy restaurant in May fair the check comes and Amy looks at me and goes we got this I don't go we got this is like three thousand pounds I'm like use of expensive dinner. So like no, no, no, we got it. So we're in the cab on the way back to the hotel And I go He got you I convinced you to pick up the check and if you look to me and she goes do you think and I go fuck yeah Yeah, I'm ready for you and said wait I paid for the check
然后我们当时在梅菲尔区一家超级高级的餐厅，账单拿来时，艾米看着我说了句：“这顿我们请了。”我说：“什么叫我们请了？这得三千英镑啊。”我说这么贵的晚餐。结果她说：“不、不、不，我们来付。”所以我们在回酒店的出租车上，我说：“他把你拿下了，我成功说服你来买单了。”结果她看着我问：“你觉得呢？”我说：“操，对啊，我随时准备着呢。”然后她说：“等等，我把账单付了？”
Did I ever tell you that Simon? No, I did not Yeah, that's amazing. I find it he's weird to be around Darren, you know, because you you constantly worried that he might do something strange to your mind Yeah, so Simon to be around Darren, you know, because you constantly worried that he might do something strange to your mind. So Simon, your level of astonishment is greater on the sets of Star Trek or Mission Impossible as far as execution, scope of production. Probably Mission Impossible.
我以前跟你说过这事吗，西蒙？没有，你没说过。天哪，太绝了。我觉得和达伦待在一起感觉怪怪的，你知道的，因为你总是担心他对你的大脑做什么奇怪的事。所以，西蒙，在《星际迷航》和《碟中谍》的片场，从动作戏和制作规模的执行力度来看，哪个让你更叹为观止？大概是《碟中谍》吧。
Yeah, right. Just because of the stuff that Tom Cruise does, you know, that we are witness to on the day of him jumping off a cliff on a motorbike or whatever. Oh, yeah. I mean, that just sort of is genuinely terrifying. Right, and your stunt crew and safety crew and second unit, all that stuff that just must be
没错，对吧。就因为汤姆·克鲁斯做的那些事，你知道的，我们在现场亲眼目睹他骑着摩托车从悬崖上飞下去之类的。哦，对。我是说，那场面真的是吓死人了。没错，还有你们的特技团队、安全团队和第二摄制组，所有这些，简直就像
like rocket scientists. Yeah, hundreds of cameras on, when we did the bike stunt, which is in Mission Impossible, Dead Rucki part one, there was a take he did where there were cameras mounted on the bike he was riding. So when he jumped off it, the bike just sort of cartwheeled away and caught him every time it spanned. And then they had to go down into the bottom of this quarry
火箭科学家一样厉害。对，拍摩托车特技时有几百个摄像机开着，那场戏在《碟中谍：致命清算（上）》里，他拍过这样一个镜头，他骑的摩托车上装满了摄像机。所以当他飞车跃下时，摩托车在空中翻滚着飞开，每次旋转都能拍到他。然后他们不得不下到这个采石场的底部
and find the bike and retrieve the cameras and find which ones were still working. And sure enough, they picked up this incredible footage of him just sort of like disappearing upwards as the bike and retrieve the cameras and find which ones were still working. And sure enough, they picked up this incredible footage of him just sort of like disappearing upwards as the bike. That's crazy. That's crazy. That's crazy. The whole tea on all departments of those movies is just insane. So, by the way, you know, I just found yesterday that I've actually got a second unit. Oh, good for you. Yeah. So, super tiny. You just discovered it. Let's find a way. But it counts, but it counts.
去找那辆摩托车，回收摄像机，看看哪些还能正常工作。果不其然，他们拍到了令人难以置信的画面，就是他向上方渐渐消失的身影，同时摩托车也……去找摩托车，回收摄像机，看看哪些还能正常工作。果不其然，他们拍到了令人难以置信的画面，就是他向上方渐渐消失的身影，同时摩托车也……太疯狂了。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。这些电影所有部门的整个团队简直疯了。顺便说一句，我昨天刚发现我其实也有个第二摄制组。哦，那恭喜你啊。对，超小型的。你刚刚才发现。总得想个办法。但这也算数，确实算数。
So wait, listen, I want to talk about, so it was for Mission Impossible 3, JJ just called you out of the blue. JJ Abrams just called you out of the blue and object. Yeah, it did. Because of Sean of the dead, right? Because of Sean, he, me and Edgibah writing hot fuzz and the phone rang and it was JJ Abrams
所以等等，听着，我想聊聊，那是为了《碟中谍3》，J·J突然给你打电话。J·J·艾布拉姆斯突然给你打了个电话，然后……对，他真的打了。因为《僵尸肖恩》对吧？因为《僵尸肖恩》，他，我和埃德加当时正在写《热血警探》，然后电话响了，是J·J·艾布拉姆斯
and he just sort of literally said, hey, do you want to come and be in the measurements of all three? And I said, yeah, okay. Please, please. Yeah, okay, why not? And I didn't know. Let me finish. I'm just at me mate. I like the finish.
他字面意思上直接说：“嘿，你想来客串《碟中谍3》吗？”我说：“行啊，好啊。求之不得，求之不得。”“行啊，好啊，为什么不呢？”我当时还不知道。让我说完。我只是在说我的哥们。我喜欢听完。
I was kind of in the same way. He emailed me about Star Trek and just said, do you want to play Scotty? I think he got bored of looking for someone and just, I get that other guy that I got last time. Wow. I mean, it is unusual to be part, it is unusual to be part of such big kind of iconic
我当时也差不多是这样。他给我发了封关于《星际迷航》的邮件，就问：“你想演史考迪吗？”我想他是懒得找别人了，就直接找了上回合作过的那家伙。哇。我是说，能参与这样规模宏大、标志性的
friendships that are very different. Unless you're Harrison Ford. Unless you're Harrison Ford, that's right. Yeah, Harrison Ford, you're the king. You're the British Harrison Ford. I've heard that before. It's, thank you. When you say your biggest regret was hiring,
系列电影，而且体验完全不同，这确实很不寻常。除非你是哈里森·福特。除非你是哈里森·福特，没错。对，哈里森·福特，你才是王。你就是英国的哈里森·福特。我以前听人这么说过。谢谢。当你觉得你最大的遗憾是雇了，
was hiring Beatman for Paul. That was a huge regret. Let's get to Paul. I was listening to Hayda the other day on the podcast talking about those jalapeno shooters. And you weren't there that day. It was me, Nick, and Hayda. And they gave us these tequila shots
是为《保罗》雇了贝特曼。那可真是个巨大的遗憾。我们来聊聊《保罗》。我前几天听海达在播客里聊起那些墨西哥辣椒烈酒果冻。你那天不在现场。当时只有我和尼克还有海达。他们给我们倒了这些龙舌兰酒
with jalapeno juice. And we'd shot lava the next day. Oh my God. I'm glad you weren't there. I feel like the sake of your bottom. He doesn't remember where he was yesterday, so that's the good news. But you remember when we gave you a Teen Wolf 2 poster at the end? Yes, your rap gift. I do. We'll sign it. I do remember that. I was very warned by that. Where is it? Where is it Jason? I saw that. Binned. Yeah. We're in Binned. Binned. Immediately Binned.
里面加了墨西哥辣椒汁。结果我们第二天拉肚子拉得像岩浆一样。天哪。我真庆幸你当时不在。为了你的屁股着想。他连自己昨天在哪都不记得了，所以这是个好消息。但你还记得我们在杀青时送了你一张《少狼2》的海报吗？记得，那是你们的杀青礼物。我记得。我们还签名了。我当然记得。我当时被感动坏了。那海报呢？那海报在哪，杰森？我看到了。扔了。对。扔哪了？扔了。直接扔了。
I sold that. Bend. Yeah. Bend. Bend. Immediately bend. Okay. Jay, get that framed. How unbelievably rude.
我卖了。扔了。对。扔了。扔了。马上就扔了。好吧。杰，把它拿去装裱起来。怎么能这么粗鲁无礼。
No, I think it came framed. It was framed. But then you unframed it. I thought you told me you unframed it. It's you just sell it easier. It's the first roll of nothing else. Yeah. Wait, I want to go back.
不，我觉得它本来就是带框的。当时是装了框的。但后来你把它拆框了。我记得你跟我说过你把框拆了。这样更容易卖掉。这是毫无疑问的第一准则。对。等等，我想倒回去。
So in 2009, you completed the second installment of your nerd trifecta, which again, is a real thing. With Star Trek, who helped you with your Scottish accent? Was it hard like do you have Scots in your family? Yeah, I married to a Scott and I had a glass region. So her dad helped me. Sean's married to a Scott too. Yeah. There you go. Nice ride. Yeah, we, yeah, we, I got help from the family on that, because they're the first people to. Although they kept trying to make me put, like, this is a Tordry little Scottish rudeness into the script.
所以在2009年，你完成了你的书呆子三部曲中的第二部，这确实是实打实的成就。在拍《星际迷航》时，是谁帮你练苏格兰口音的？很难吗？你家里有苏格兰血统吗？对，我娶了个苏格兰老婆，而且我有个格拉斯哥岳父。所以她爸爸帮了我。肖恩也娶了个苏格兰老婆，对吧？对。没错。太棒了。对，我们，对，我从家里的长辈那里得到了很多帮助，因为他们是最先……尽管他们一直试图让我在剧本里加点，比如这种俗气的小小的苏格兰粗鲁俚语。
I did actually try a few things, but JJ came up to me and said, I mean, they've got to understand what you're saying. Let's hear just a little bit. You have a rudeness thing you could say, since Scottish. I do actually say there's a famous Scottish, Glaswegian saying which is getty fuck. If you're instead of like, you know, shut up or get out of it, it's getty fuck.
我其实尝试了几种，但J·J走到我面前对我说：“我是说，观众得听得懂你在说什么才行。”让我们听一听一小段。你有什么可以说出口的苏格兰粗口吗？我还真知道一个有名的苏格兰格拉斯哥方言，就是“getty fuck”。如果你想表达类似于“闭嘴”或者“滚一边去”，那就是“getty fuck”。
And in the first Star Trek, I do actually say to Deep Roy who plays my little wingman, you hear me go getty. And I don't, so anyone who's Scottish would know exactly what I was about. Oh, that's great. That's great. Oh, wow. That's crazy. And then you got, get tiff. So anyone who's Scottish would know exactly what I was about. That's great. That's great. Oh wow. That's crazy.
在第一部《星际迷航》里，我确实对扮演我小跟班的迪普·罗伊说过这句，你能听到我说了“getty”。我不信，所以任何懂苏格兰话的人都会立刻明白我在说什么。哦，太棒了。太棒了。哦，哇。这太疯狂了。然后你还学会了，get tiff。所以任何懂苏格兰话的人都会立刻明白我在说什么。太棒了。太棒了。哦，哇。这太疯狂了。
And then you got to a right one, like in six months. Yeah, that was... How did you get to a right? That was like someone giving you the keys to a really, really expensive car. It was the hardest thing I've ever done, just because we had no time. And Justin Lin, who was the director,
然后你还得写一部，在六个月内完成。对，那真是……你是怎么写出来的？那感觉就像有人把一辆非常非常贵豪车的钥匙交给了你。那是我做过最难的事情，因为我们完全没有时间。而导演林诣彬，
who's a director, who's a brilliant, brilliant guy, but he's not a verbal communicator, and it was really hard to understand what he wanted at first, like he used to drive you insane. And there's some people now that start track beyond, sorry. Start track beyond, yeah. And myself and Doug Jung, we wrote that script together, but it was loads of fun. And Doug came to stay with me in the UK and we'd write during the day and then at night, we'd watch episodes of the original series
他是一位导演，是个绝顶聪明、才华横溢的人，但他不太擅长用语言沟通，刚开始的时候很难弄懂他到底想要什么，他简直能把你逼疯。而且现在还有一些关于《星际迷航：超越星辰》的讨论，抱歉。《星际迷航：超越星辰》，对。我和道格·姜一起合写了那个剧本，不过过程特别好玩。道格还来我在英国的家里住过，我们白天写剧本，晚上就看原版电视剧的剧集
just to try and get little Easter eggs to put in. And we eventually ended up. I, you know, weirdly, it was the first time I'd faced the idea of being rewritten by someone else. And, that's a while. You know, we worked really hard on it and then our producer, Lindsay Coulden said, we're gonna get some fresh eyes on the script.
纯粹是为了找出里面可以藏的小彩蛋。我们最终完成了。说实话，这很奇妙，这是我第一次面对被别人重写剧本的情况。而且，这花了一段时间。你知道的，我们为之付出了巨大的努力，然后我们的制片人林赛·柯顿说：“我们得找点新鲜的视角来润色一下剧本。”
And I was like, what the fuck? Like, I never experienced that before. And I was so incensed and angry that, how dare you? Like, I think, you know, I come from my cushy little British film making background. Well, Sean's mom used to get fresh eyes about every two months, right? Is that right? LAUGHTER So what we did was we'd get... Justin Lin would send us the rewrites,
我当时就想：什么鬼？我以前从来没经历过这种事。我当时气炸了，心想：你怎么敢这么做？我想，你知道的，我带着我那舒适的小英国电影制作背景。好吧，肖恩的妈妈差不多每两个月就要换一次“新鲜视角”，对吧？是这样吗？（笑声）所以我们的做法是……林诣彬会把修改意见发给我们，
and then Dog and I would secretly rewrite them, and then send them back to Justin, and then Justin would deliver them to Paramount as his notes. So we would secretly rewrite the rewrites. If you're listening to this Paramount, then it'll work. Okay. That's fucking great. What a great way to rig the system in your paper. Yeah, that's why I just can't just get rewritten it all on Paul. No, and it shows no. No, the Lorenzo. No, we didn't. no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I'm not saying you're actually one of the most supreme comedy double takes. I have ever witnessed in any comedy forum.
然后道格和我会秘密地把那些修改意见重新改掉，再发回给林诣彬，接着林诣彬就会把这些作为他自己的意见提交给派拉蒙。所以我们实际上是在秘密重写那些重写意见。如果你在听这个节目，派拉蒙，那就这么着吧。好吧。太牛逼了。这真是一个把体制玩弄于股掌之间的绝妙方法。对，这就是为什么我不能让别人随便重写《保罗》的剧本。不，事实证明确实没有。不，罗伦佐……不，我们没有。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，同感，你绝对是我见过的在任何喜剧形式中表现最顶级的喜剧双人反应之一。
It wasn't a joke that like it was the first time I'd really heard it said. And I was like, oh fuck. Why? You go, we go, you say something like, thank you, Agents, as I only go, call me Lorenzo. And we go, Lorenzo, I'm not, oh, fuck. And what? You go, we go, agent, you say something like, thank you, Agent Zoily, you go, call me Lorenzo. And we go, Lorenzo's oil, and you go, yeah. Then you sort of do this, like, you suddenly heard it for the first time. And it's just fucking sublime, Jason. It really is.
那不是个笑话，就像那是第一次我真的听到有人这么说。当时我就想：哦，操。为什么？你说，我们说，你说了句类似的话，比如“谢谢你，佐伊特工”，然后我说：“叫我罗伦佐。”然后我们说：“罗伦佐的油”，然后你说：“对。”接着你就会做出这种反应，就像你突然第一次听到这个梗一样。这简直太绝了，杰森。真的是绝了。
It really just, it's just textbook. It's not surprising that I remember a little of that because I think it was a night shoot, if memory serves. It was a night shoot, yeah. We were up on the ski ball with Sigourney Weaver. And Daos, as Kristen Wigg used to call it, Daos. Daos, that's right. So Edgar Wright, who we've already established
这真的就是教科书级别的。我能记住一点也不奇怪，因为如果我没记错的话，那应该是一场夜戏。那是一场夜戏，对。我们当时和西格妮·韦弗一起在雪球（Skee-Ball）游艺场。还有达奥斯，克里斯汀·韦格以前就是这么叫他的，达奥斯。达奥斯，没错。所以埃德加·怀特，我们刚才已经确定了
is one of your besties and does a lot of stuff. I didn't know this. I didn't know he wrote and directed Baby Driver. I love that movie. I love it. I love it. Really? I mean, that is a master. He had that script for a long time. Yeah. And I hear I heard you do somewhere and impression of him. Can you do just a little bit of Edgar? You're right. He'll listen to this and they'll kill me. He does listen to it. His voice is quite high. That's terrible. He gets quite drunk. Can he say he's talking to your ear, you're quite loud.
他是你们的死党之一，而且拍了很多作品。我之前都不知道。我以前不知道他编剧并执导了《极盗车神》。我超爱那部电影。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。真的吗？我的天，那真是一部大师之作。他那个剧本捂了很久。对。我听说你在什么地方模仿过他的声音。你能稍微模仿一下埃德加吗？你说得对。他听到这个肯定会杀了我的。他确实会听这节目。他的声音挺尖的。太糟糕了。他喝高的时候声音会变尖。他会说他在你耳边说话，你声音太大了。
Oh my God. Oh my God. It was a right to come on the show now himself and effort. We got to get him on the show. He does. He does send me reviews of episodes sometimes and via text. Well, after my phone numbers still the same, where's my text? Not reviews, but he'll say, I really enjoyed it.
我的天呐。我的天呐。埃德加真该自己来上这个节目。我们得请他来节目里。他确实会。他有时会通过短信给我发一些对节目的评价。好吧，我的电话号码还没变，我的短信呢？不是评价，但他会说：“我真的很喜欢。”
I could listen to you do that for nine hours. Nick does it really well as well. It's got it, it's very high. It's kind of like a tarot act tool. LAUGHTER Oh, my God. Oh. But he is, you know, I mean, I've kind of,
我能听你模仿这个听上九个小时。尼克也模仿得特别好。声音很高。有点像塔罗牌占卜师。（笑声）我的天呐。噢。但他确实是，你知道的，我可以说，
one of the luckiest moments of my life meeting at Gadjust because he is such an extraordinary talent. And, you know, I love him a bit, so I'm sure he'll forgive me for doing his voice. Quiet like this. We'll be right back. SmartList is supported by rocket money. Now, if are you like me, do you have kids that have apps on your, you kind of like share an account and it's,
我生命中最幸运的时刻之一就是遇到了埃德加，因为他真的是个极其非凡的天才。而且，你知道的，我很喜欢他，所以相信他会原谅我模仿他的声音。声音要放低成这样。我们马上回来。《SmartLess》由 Rocket Money 赞助支持。现在，如果你跟我一样，你是不是也有孩子在你们的账户里下载了各种应用，你们其实是共享一个账户的，而且我发现，
I've noticed that I've got a bunch of apps that have not been used for years, as my girls are older now and these are like little tiny little toddler apps and I've forgotten that I'm paying for them. Do you know how much your subscriptions really cost, gang? Most Americans think they spend about 80 bucks a month on subscriptions,
我有一些应用已经好几年没用了，因为我的女儿们现在都长大了，那些都是很小的时候用的幼儿应用，我都忘了我还在为它们付钱。大家知道你们的订阅服务每月实际花掉多少钱吗？大多数美国人认为他们每月在订阅上花大约80美元，
but the actual total is closer to 200. If you don't know exactly how much you're spending every month, you need rocket money. Rocket money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions. Monitors you're spending and it helps you lower your bills all in one place. Over 80% of people have subscriptions they've forgotten about and chances are you're one
但实际总额接近200美元。如果你不知道自己每个月到底花了多少钱，你需要 Rocket Money。Rocket Money 是一款个人理财应用，能帮你找到并取消不想要的订阅，
of them. Just like, you know, like a streaming app that you do watch a show that you no longer watch, it's still there costing you money, rocket money would help you figure that out. Now, they will also quickly and easily find your subscriptions for you and for any you don't want to pay for anymore. You just hit cancel. It's super simple. Rocket money. Well, cancel it for you. It's that easy. Rocket money also helps you manage all your finances in one place and automatically categorizes your expenses so you can easily track your budget in real time. You can also get alerted if anything
监控你的消费，还能帮你削减账单，所有功能都在一个地方搞定。超过80%的人都有自己已经忘掉的订阅服务，而你很可能就是其中之一。就像，你知道的，某个流媒体应用，你曾看过一个节目，但现在早就不看了，它却依然在那里扣你的钱，Rocket Money 能帮你把这些找出来。现在，它们还能快速轻松地帮你找出所有的订阅服务，对于任何你不想再付费的项目，你只需点击取消。就是这么简单。Rocket Money 会帮你取消。就是这么轻松。Rocket Money 还能帮你在一处管理所有的财务状况，并自动对你的支出进行分类，让你能实时轻松追踪预算。如果有什么情况看起来不对劲，你还会收到提醒。超过300万人使用过 Rocket Money，平均每年帮每个人节省高达720美元。听起来很棒吧？你也可以成为其中一员。加入这300万人的行列吧。别再乱花冤枉钱了。取消不想要的订阅。用最轻松的方式管理你的开支。访问 rocketmoney.com 斜杠 smartless
looks off. Over 3 million people have used rocket money, saving the average person up to a $720 a year sound. That could be you. Join the 3 million. Stop throwing your money away. Cancel unwanted subscriptions. Manage your expenses the easy way. Go to rocketmoney.com slash smartless.
也就是 rocketmoney.com/smartless，rocketmoney.com/smartless。再次强调是 rocketmoney.com/smartless。rocketmoney.com/smartless。《SmartLess》得到了 Eight Sleep 的支持。现在，你知道温度是改善睡眠质量最重要的因素之一吗？我打赌你不知道。我以前也不知道，但现在我懂了，因为我入手了这个 Eight Sleep 的产品，我
That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless rocket money.com slash smartless. That's rocket money.com slash smartless. Rocket money.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from eight sleep. Now, did you know the temperature is one of the most important factors in improving your sleep quality? I bet you didn't. I did not and now I get it because I got one of these eight sleep things and I'm you didn't. I did not. And now I get it. Because I got one of these eight sleep things. And I'm going to tell you about that in a second.
我以前不知道。但现在我懂了。因为我入手了这个 Eight Sleep 的产品。我一会儿就跟你们详细说说。
But science has shown that your body temperature actually needs to drop in the early and middle part of your sleep and rise in the morning so that you can fall asleep fast and get more deep sleep. The pod cover by eight sleep fits on any bend like a fitted sheet. The pod cover by eight sleep fits on any bed like a fitted sheet. The pod cover, it improves your sleep by automatically adjusting the temperature on each side of the bed. Based on you and your partner's individual needs, it can cool down, it can warm up, and adjust based on the phases of your sleep and the environment that you're in. So, for instance, we have my wife and I am and she likes things a little cooler. I like things a little warmer.
但科学表明，你的体温实际上需要在睡眠的前期和中期下降，而在早晨上升，这样你才能更快入睡并获得更多深度睡眠。Eight Sleep 的智能床垫罩可以像床单一样完美适配任何床铺。Eight Sleep 的智能床垫罩可以像床单一样完美适配任何床铺。这个床垫罩，它会根据你和你伴侣各自的需求，自动调节床铺两侧的温度，从而改善你的睡眠。它可以变凉，可以变暖，并根据你的睡眠阶段以及你所处的环境进行调整。所以，举个例子，我和我妻子，她喜欢稍微凉爽一点的环境。我喜欢稍微暖和一点的。
Sometimes I like things a little bit cooler and she likes things a little warmer. Guys, the pod cover folks at 8th sleep, they figured all this out. I guess we're not the only couple like that. And also, I can wake up, I can track how well I slept. It'll tell me how great we both did me and pod cover together as a team had we get through the night. It's pretty great. Invest in the rest you deserve with the eight sleep pod. Go to eightsleep.com slash smart list and save $150 on the pod cover by eight sleep. That's the best offered you're gonna find,
有时我喜欢稍微凉快点，而她喜欢暖和点。伙计们，Eight Sleep 的智能床垫罩团队，他们把这些全都琢磨透了。看来我们不是唯一有这种烦恼的夫妻。而且，我还能醒来查看我睡得有多好。它会告诉我，我和床垫罩作为团队配合得有多好，我们是怎么度过这一整夜的。真的很棒。投资你应得的优质睡眠，选择 Eight Sleep 床垫。访问 eightsleep.com/smartless，购买 Eight Sleep 智能床垫罩即可立省 150 美元。这是你能找到的最优惠折扣，
but you must visit 8Sleep.com slash SmartList for that $150 off. 8Sleep currently ships within the USA, Canada, the UK, select countries in the EU, and Australia. And now back to the show. I remember like it was yesterday, although I'm not sure of some of the details, but I'm pretty sure it was a screening of hot fuzz that I believe you were there with me, Willie, that we got invited to and I met you and Nick and Edgar and Edgar or you, all you guys had loved to rest the development. Like that's why we were there. That's how we got invited. And then I remember that is being one of the
但你必须访问 8Sleep.com/Smartless 才能享受这 150 美元的优惠。8Sleep 目前向美国、加拿大、英国、欧盟部分国家以及澳大利亚发货。现在让我们回到节目中。我记得那感觉就像发生在昨天一样，尽管我对一些细节记不太清了，但我很确定那是《热血警探》的一场放映会，威利，我相信你当时也在场，我们受邀出席了，然后我遇到了你、尼克、埃德加，还有埃德加或者你们所有人都非常喜欢《发展受阻》。这就是为什么我们在那里的原因。这就是我们受邀的原因。然后我记得那是其中一次
first times that I thought, oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, Judge. Oh, yeah, it was, it was the screening of extract. Extract. Extract. Yeah, that's it. Simon, did we go together or something? Were we met up there with Edgar or something? That's right. And then, then afterwards, we were in the bar and then you, me, Amy, and you guys and Amy and me. And there was some,
初次让我觉得，哦，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，巴勃罗·杰奇。哦，对，那是《提取》的放映会。提取。《提取》。对，就是那部。西蒙，是我们一起去的吗？还是我们在那儿跟埃德加碰头的？没错。然后后来，我们在酒吧里，接着你、我、艾米，还有你们几个，还有艾米和我。还有一些，
I remember there was some paparazzi shots of us all kind of like hanging off each other and smiling and drinking. And I remember there was some paparazzi shots of us all kind of like hanging off each other and smiling and drinking. And I remember being really just I drinking. I don't know. I was still drinking at that time. No, you weren't Jason. You were not. No, I was still I was still on it in those days, but no, what Paul's when you write when you got sober, right around that time? Just after Paul. Yeah, I was I was pretty drunk through Paul, but it was like a year off of that. I got drunk for you. Good for you. I have to fan out because I'm not going to have to use. Go, Sean.
我记得有一些我们的狗仔队照片，大家互相搭着肩膀、笑着喝酒。我记得当时真的是……我在喝酒。我不知道，我那时候还在喝酒。不对，杰森，你没有。你真的没有。不，我还在……那时候我还在喝，不过不，说到《保罗》，你是什么时候戒酒的？就在那前后？拍完《保罗》之后。对，我拍《保罗》时喝得挺厉害的，但那之后大约一年，我戒酒了。真为你高兴。我得去追星了，因为我等下没空。上吧，肖恩。
So, Star Wars universe and Star Wars world and like growing up was that surreal getting like invited into that world and then like, you know, being around Carrie Fisher and all of those people. And was that you behind the thing for six portions. Was that you, that big guy? Yeah, that was me in the big fat suit, yeah. And was that all CGI? Was that just... They CGI'd my face a little bit,
所以，关于《星球大战》宇宙和《星球大战》世界，从小到大，被邀请进入那个世界是什么感觉，然后，你知道的，能和凯丽·费舍尔以及所有人在一起。六个食量背后的那个人是你吗？那个大块头真的是你吗？对，穿着厚重大胖子戏服的就是我。那全都是CGI特效吗？还是说……他们稍微用CGI处理了一下我的脸，
just to make me look less human, but it was a big suit and... Yeah, he was called Oncar Plut. And he owned the Millennium Falcon, which is like, you know, I was very happy the fact that I have now owned the Millennium Falcon and been the engineer on the Starship Enterprise. I know, it's so insane, that's insane.
只是为了让我看起来没那么像人类，但这套戏服很大……对，他叫昂卡·普拉特（Onkar Plutt）。他拥有千年隼号，这就意味着，你知道的，我非常开心，因为我现在既拥有过千年隼号，又当过星际迷航企业号的工程师。我知道，太疯狂了，这太疯狂了。
But wait, so growing up and were you a fan, and then now you're in it, and you're around Carrie Fisher, and Harrison Ford, I mean, were you like... Yeah, it was extraordinary. I mean, that set as well, the Force Awakens, because it felt very much like the first star, was the star was I grew up loving. And to be around those guys, I was on set the day when Harrison Ford and Hannon Chouy came onto the Millennium Falcon again for the first time. Crazy, I cried. I cried like a child.
但等等，所以从小到大你是个粉丝，然后现在你身处其中，周围都是凯丽·费舍尔和哈里森·福特，我是说，你当时是不是……对，太非凡了。我是说，片场也是，《原力觉醒》的片场，因为感觉非常像是第一部星战，也就是我从小看到大并深爱的星战。能和那些家伙在一起，我记得哈里森·福特和楚巴卡再次登上千年隼号的那天，我就在片场。太疯狂了，我都哭了。我像个孩子一样哭了。
And then I had a great, I've told this story before, but it's a good story, it's worth telling. I had a massive crush on Carrie Fisher when I was a kid. I mean, she was the first romantic love that I remember of feeling, you know, and I would kiss her picture before I went to sleep, and I was just so in love with her. Did you breathe return to the Jedi before even, you know... Well, you had a poster and you'd make out with a poster or something? I kind of kissed it quite sort of coily,
然后我有一段很棒的经历，这个故事我以前讲过，但这是个好故事，值得再讲一遍。我小时候对凯丽·费舍尔迷恋得不行。我是说，她是我有记忆以来第一个产生浪漫爱意的人，你知道的，我在睡觉前都会亲吻她的照片，我是那么地深爱着她。你在《绝地归来》上映前就……好吧，你有一张海报，然后你会对着海报亲热什么的？我当时亲得很矜持，
because I wasn't, I was seven, eight, I think I was, when I saw stars. It didn't get to the UK till 1978. So I'm on set with her and we're walking around this. Oh well, just like a world's face, just trying to come up with a, what, what would the poster that Sean has? Oh my, oh, oh, Sean? Yeah, to Sean. Light savers. She, she, we walk around the set of the resistance base, Arm and Arm, and I was kind of chatting with her and stuff.
因为我当时……我才七、八岁吧，我看《星战》的时候。直到1978年它才引进到英国。所以我当时和她一起在片场，我们手挽着手走在基地布景里，我一边和她聊天什么的。
And I stopped and I looked at her in her eyes and I said, you know, and the thing was, it was the same fucking eyes. It was the same. I know that's an obvious thing to say, but it was her eyes, the eyes that I had just dreamed of ever looking into as a kid. And I said, you know, I've always loved you, don't you? Oh, God. She grabbed my hand and she looked at my wedding and she went, fuck you. just dreamed of ever looking into his kid. And I said, you know, I've always loved you, don't you? Oh, God. She grabbed my hand and she looked at my wedding ring. And she went, fuck you. I thought, oh, nice.
然后我停下脚步，看着她的眼睛说道，你知道吗，最绝的是，那就是一模一样的他妈的眼睛。一模一样。我知道这么说有点显而易见，但那就是她的眼睛，正是我小时候做梦都想凝视的那双眼睛。然后我对她说：“你知道吗，我一直都很爱妳，妳知道的吧？”天哪。她抓起我的手，看着我的结婚戒指，然后说：“去你的。”我小时候做梦都想凝视的那双眼睛。然后我对她说：“你知道吗，我一直都很爱妳，妳知道的吧？”天哪。她抓起我的手，看着我的结婚戒指，然后说：“去你的。”我心想：哦，真棒。
Really? This is so funny. She was the best. She said, you know, the one thing she said to me when I first met her years and years and years and years ago, never met her in my whole life was sitting right next to her at this dinner. And she goes, you know, Han Solo and I were fucking the whole time.
真的吗？太搞笑了。她太棒了。她说，当年我第一次见她时——那是好多年、好多年、好多年以前的事了，我这辈子从没见过她——当时我就坐在她旁边的一场晚宴上，她对我说：“你知道吗，韩·索罗和我当时一直在乱搞。”
And I was like, Blah! I was like, what? It completely shattered, like everything. There's that roast she did. I think it's a roast of Harrison Ford or something, but she starts talking and she starts talking about how nervous Harrison Ford looks
我当时就震惊了！我心想：什么？这完全颠覆了，就像一切都碎了。她不是做过那个恶搞吐槽秀吗？我想那是针对哈里森·福特的吐槽大会什么的，她开始发言，聊起哈里森·福特看起来有多紧张，
because he doesn't know what she's gonna say because obviously shit happened. All right, all right. Okay, so there you are. So now it was forced away. Can you say that what were you talking about? That was what I was in. Yeah, that's the force away.
因为他根本不知道她会说出什么来，因为显然过去发生过那些事。行了，行了。好吧，所以你就在那儿。所以那是《原力觉醒》。你能说说你刚才在聊什么吗？那正是我参演的作品。对，那是《原力觉醒》。
Yeah, because that was like 30 years after the Battle of Endor, right? And, and- Fuck you, Will. No, hang on, I'm- Yeah. So they're on, I'm just trying to think, because there and, and, fuck you, Will. No, hang on, I'm, so they're on the, I'm just trying to think because, because there's that pilot, which is named Poe Dameron and he's on the desert planet of, of Jack who.
对，因为那是恩多战役大约30年后的事，对吧？然后——去你的，威利。不，等等，我——对。所以他们正在，我只是在想，因为那里面有，去你的，威利。不，等等，我，所以他们正在，我只是在想，因为那里有个飞行员，名叫波·达默龙，他在那个沙漠星球，杰库。
You look at it with the padi. Yeah. No, what? Yeah. He is. Okay. Oh, this is so boring. I can't believe they were on Jack who.
你看着那个帕迪。对。不，什么？对。他是。好吧。这太无聊了。我不敢相信他们当时在杰库。
That whole time, that guy. By the way, did you notice, did you, did you, did you notice that some people say, in that movie, some people say, Jakku and other people say, Jakku. Of course I fucking noticed it, dude. It's Jakku. Of course. It's Jakku, right.
从头到尾，那家伙。顺便问一句，你有没有注意到，你有没有注意到，有的人在那部电影里说的是“贾库”（Jakku），而另其他人说的是“雅库”（Jakku）。我他妈当然注意到了，老兄！那就是“贾库”。当然了。是“贾库”，对吧。
It's a double K, come on. Of course I noticed it and then I went and I bought a rope and I bought a chair and I was like, what would be a good spot for this? Fuck it, hell. Okay, give, but wait. I say that. Oh, I would love you knowing that love.
两个K，拜托。我当然注意到了，然后我跑去买了一根绳子和一把椅子，心想：这地方挂哪比较合适？去他妈的，见鬼。好吧，给个……但等等。我这么说。哦，我好喜欢你懂这个梗。
Wait, so sometimes, some so after the Star Wars are one of this 27 Star Trek, whatever, you said you, I read that you went on vacation and you said, don't, I don't want, you're told you're agent, I don't want anybody to bother me. No, I don't want any phone calls. Only if it's Steven Spielberg. Yeah, Steven Spielberg actually fucking all to you. And tell you what. Oh my God.
等等，所以有时候，有些……所以在《星战》、《星际迷航》之后，我看到报道说你去度假了，你对经纪人说：“别，我不想让任何人来打扰我。”不，我不要任何电话。除非是史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格。对，史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格还真他妈给你打电话了。然后跟你说。天哪。
He phoned and said, will you come and be in Ready Player One? Yes, I love that movie too. And which is obviously an incredible call to get. And we'd work with him, you know, because he does a little cameo and Paul as well. So I'd work with him on 10-10 and then he came in and did his little bit in Paul. And then I got to do Ready Player One. And to work with him on Tin Tin and then he came in and did his little bit in Paul and then... And then I got to do Ready Play One and to work with him is a dream, you know.
他打电话来说：“你愿意来演《头号玩家》吗？”当然，我也超爱那部电影。这显然是一个超级棒的电话。而且我们以前跟他合作过，你知道的，因为他在《保罗》里也有个小客串。所以我在《丁丁历险记》里跟他合作过，然后他来《保罗》里客串了一个小角色。后来我又接到了《头号玩家》。在《丁丁历险记》里跟他合作，然后他又来客串了《保罗》，接着……然后我就演了《头号玩家》，能和他合作简直就像做梦一样，你知道的。
He's just the most extraordinary. Yeah, of course. I mean, he's everything that I loved about cinema as a kid, and as an adult. And he's very willing to sort of chat about his career and stuff. He's really, really... I love that. Without crowing, you know, he'll just tell you stories about jaws and close and cannas. And it's just such a privilege, you know. He was at Sean's opening night.
他简直是最非凡的……对，当然。我是说，他代表了我小时候以及成年后对电影所有的热爱。而且他非常乐意聊聊他的职业生涯什么的。他真的、真的很……我太喜欢这样了。他不会自吹自擂，你知道的，他就是会给你讲一些关于《大白鲨》、《第三类接触》和《夺宝奇兵》的故事。这真是一种特权，你知道的。他当时就在肖恩的首映之夜现场。
Oh, did he go see a play? He's an investor, nice fella. Oh, wow. I know. He's been on the show. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Last year. Super nice.
哦，他去看话剧了吗？他是投资人，人挺好的。哦，哇。我知道。他上过这个节目。对，对，对。去年。超级好。
Wait, so ready to play one. So then you talked a little bit about the English, you talked about a little bit like American humor versus English humor. And about a little bit like American humor versus English humor, and like how something about like, something about like how we always say, just kidding or something, but Americans like,
等等，所以说到《头号玩家》。然后你们刚才聊了一下英国人，聊了一点美国幽默与英国幽默的对比，还聊到了一些类似于……比如我们总是说“开玩笑啦”或者类似的话，但美国人喜欢……
yeah, well that's sort of, there's a weird thing, and it comes from a lot of sort of snobbishness, snobbishness in British comedy circle sometimes, and that you hear our Americans, they don't do irony. And it's such a bullshit statement because Americans do some of the greatest irony ever. You guys just don't use it so much socially.
对，那是种很奇怪的现象，它源于英国喜剧圈里有时存在的某种势利眼，你会听到有人说“美国人不懂反讽”。这简直是句扯淡的话，因为美国人运用过有史以来最棒的反讽。只是你们在社交场合不怎么经常使用罢了。
I present company accepted, I mean, Jason particularly, because you got a British mom, right? So you don't just try it and many it deserts. And I'm usually grumpy, so it's kind of a double negative. So yeah, you're virtually very hungry. He's hungry. So hungry.
在座各位除外，我是说杰森尤其如此，因为你有个英国妈妈，对吧？所以你不会只试一次就放弃。而且我通常脾气都不好，所以这算是个双重否定。所以，对，你实际上非常饿。他饿了。饿坏了。
But because British people are very ashamed of their emotions, they just wrap everything in sarcasm and are only that. It's socially, you know. But I think American people generally are just a little less uptight. And so if they do say something, try, they'll qualify it as just kidding, just in case that person thinks that they were being serious, which is very right.
但因为英国人对自己的情绪感到非常羞耻，他们在社交场合总是用讽刺和反讽把一切情绪包裹起来，你知道的。但我认为美国人总体上要稍微放松一些。所以如果他们说了什么带讽刺意味的话，他们会加上一句“开玩笑啦”来作限定，以防对方以为他们是认真的，这其实非常体贴。
But you only have to watch. I mean, arrested is a great example of a brilliantly dry comedy show. You know, it's... I actually started showing my 14-year-old daughter the other day, which was great, because it meant I could sort of go back to the beginning. And it's such a good example of dry American humor at its best. Yeah.
但你只需要看着就行。我的意思是，《发展受阻》就是一个干瘪幽默喜剧的绝佳例子。你知道，它……其实前几天我开始给我14岁的女儿看，这太棒了，因为这意味着我可以从头看起。这真是美国干瘪幽默的典范之作。是的。
But it pales in comparison to all the money Python stuff, I mean, the British office. I mean, that whole style of not winking and just playing everything as a drama. Yeah. But a deeply flawed character in a drama. Like then you've got a real good humor. Yeah. Wait, so another mission impossible coming out soon on July 12th.
但与巨蟒剧团的那些作品相比，它就黯然失色了，我是说，英国版的《办公室》。那种不眨眼、完全当成正剧来演的风格。是的。但却是一个有严重缺陷的正剧角色。这样才真正有好的幽默感。等一下，所以另一部《碟中谍》很快要上映了，在7月12日。
Are you guys just doing a row? Yeah, are you filming the second part now? We're in the midst of doing two in a row. Oh my God. We've stopped filming now so they can finish Dead Rekking Part One and then we go out on a big press tour over the summer. We'll be in New York, free tickets to your show, please. But the last go, I think it's Denny.
你们是在连着拍吗？是的，你们现在在拍第二部吗？我们正在连拍两部。天哪。我们现在暂停拍摄了，好让它们完成《碟中谍7（上）》的后期，然后我们在夏天要进行一次盛大的宣传巡演。我们会去纽约，请送我你演出的免费门票，拜托。不过最后一次，我想是丹尼。
Any time you want. The last go, the Tabasco Theatre. The Tabasco Theatre. It's a hard sell on there. It's a fast, spicy show. And then we go back to shooting in August and then we complete Part Two, which will be our next year. And it's been a hell, I mean, we started shooting
随时奉陪。最后一次，塔巴斯科剧院。塔巴斯科剧院。那里的票很难卖。这是一场节奏快、火辣的演出。然后我们在八月份恢复拍摄，接着完成第二部，那将是我们的下一年。而且这太疯狂了，我是说，我们开始拍摄
this one in 2020 in the September of 2020. Wow. It's taken us three years to shoot this movie. Wow, that's amazing. Right in the thick of the hoax. I mean, we kind of, what did I say? You said hoax, yeah. I mean, Simon, you haven't say? You said hoax, yeah.
这部是在2020年，2020年的9月。哇。我们花了三年时间才拍完这部电影。哇，太惊人了。正处于骗局最严重的时候。我是说，我们有点，我刚才说什么了？你说了骗局，对。我是说，西蒙，你还没说？你说了骗局，对。
I mean Simon, you haven't stopped. You haven't stopped making great stuff. I know. Like 20 years. Yeah, I know. I mean, I... I want to get to that. Like do you geek out?
我是说，西蒙，你一直没停下。你一直没有停止创作优秀的作品。我知道。就像20年来。是的，我知道。我是说，我……我想谈谈这个。比如你会像个极客一样吗？
Like I would if I were you, when you get the scripts that you get or you produce or make. Like are you a fan of the genre like I am? And you know what I mean? Like you like, oh this is so cool. Yeah, I think I am, but I feel like I've aged you don't even mean like you like oh this is yeah I think I am but I feel like I've aged out a little bit of stuff that I I've not kind of kept up with all the new
就像我要是你的话也会那样，当你拿到那些剧本，或者你制作、创作的时候。比如你像我一样是这个类型的粉丝吗？你知道我的意思吗？就像你会觉得，哇，这太酷了。是的，我想我是，但我觉得我年纪有点大了，你甚至不懂我的意思，就像你会觉得，哇，这太酷了。是的，我想我是，但我觉得我年纪有点大了，对一些东西有点跟不上了，我没有一直关注所有那些新的
sort of Star Wars TV shows and stuff yeah that's not to say that it's not because I I'm sure I have I catch you up just comment I'll catch you if you're ring afterwards. Well yeah Sam what kind of stuff are you watching comedy-wise? Because I'm trying to think if I watch any comedies, really, it's been a while. Is there anything that's kind of... I started watching the show last night. I think you should leave on Netflix.
类似于《星球大战》的电视剧之类的内容，是的，这倒不是说它不好，因为我确信我有，我回头联系你，我打给你。好吧，西蒙，从喜剧的角度来看，你在看什么类型的节目？因为我在想我是不是看过什么喜剧，真的，已经好久没看了。有什么节目是那种……我昨晚开始看一个节目。Netflix上的《I Think You Should Leave》。
Oh, yeah, yeah. I've heard about that. That's great. I'm writing it down. It's ridiculous. Yeah, it's really good. I just rewatched it with somebody. Because the episodes are like 16 minutes long. I've heard about that. That's great. I'm writing it down. It's ridiculous. Yeah, it's really good. I just rewatched it with somebody because it's so, because the episodes are like sort of
哦，对，对。我听说过那个。太棒了。我记下来了。太荒谬了。是的，真的很好。我刚刚和别人一起重看了一遍。因为每集只有大约16分钟长。我听说过那个。太棒了。我记下来了。太荒谬了。是的，真的很好。我刚刚和别人一起重看了一遍，因为它是如此，因为每集大概
16 minutes long. They're not that long. And I just got one year in Atlanta. I got Eli to go through and I watched them all again with him and they were just brilliant. Yeah, it's really strange and but hilarious in a way that, in the way that like Python used to be, you know, like sort of slightly baffling. It's a pretty short show. No, sure, exactly why you're like Python used to be, you know, like sort of slightly baffling. It's a brilliant show.
16分钟长。它们没那么长。我刚在亚特兰大看了一年。我让伊莱陪我把它们又全看了一遍，它们真的太棒了。是的，它非常古怪，但又搞笑，就像以前的巨蟒剧团那样，你知道的，有点让人摸不头脑。这是一部相当短的节目。不，当然，为什么你会觉得像以前的巨蟒剧团，你知道的，有点让人摸不头脑。这是一部精彩的节目。
Not sure exactly why you're looking. No, it's American. Shot here, Tim Robinson, brilliant, brilliant guy. And as you know, the very nature of, we have a lot of people from SNL on here over the years, the last few years, the nature of sketch comedy is that it's really inconsistent. It's so hard to, from sketch to sketch to always be strong or always be good. In that show, I think you should leave those first six episodes.
不确定你到底在看什么。不，它是美国的。在这里拍摄的，蒂姆·罗宾逊，一个非常非常才华横溢的人。正如你所知，我们这些年请了很多周六夜现场（SNL）的人来这里，素描喜剧（小品喜剧）的本质就是它真的很不稳定。从一个短剧到另一个短剧，要一直保持强势或一直保持精彩是太难了。在那部剧中，我觉得《I Think You Should Leave》的前六集……
Oh, you told me about that. I can't. Oh, consistently good. Every sketch. You did watch it. Yeah, really good. That was a while ago. Yeah, really.
哦，你跟我说过这个。我不能。哦，始终如一地精彩。每一个小品。你真的看了。是的，真的很棒。那是好久以前的事了。是的，真的。
Simon, wait, I just, I'm sorry, this is the last mission possible question just because I'm a pro. Do you get to, because it's so, your character's so funny and like, it's so natural that do you get to write your own lines like are they cool with that? Because it sounds like not really. I mean we don't really have a script It's a very strange way of working really kind of make it up as we go along
西蒙，等等，我只是，对不起，这是最后一个关于《碟中谍》的问题，因为我是个职业粉丝。你能够，因为你的角色太搞笑了，而且非常自然，你可以自己写台词吗？他们对此不介意吗？因为听起来好像并不是这样。我是说我们真的没有剧本，这是一种非常奇怪的工作方式，真的是边拍边编。
I don't believe it but that's great. It's true. I have not ever read a script for the film I've just made What Tom and McQ Chris McQuarrion Tom Cruise they know the story they know the big set pieces script for the film I've just made. What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What?
我不信，但那太棒了。真的。我从来没有为我刚拍完的那部电影读过剧本。汤姆和麦奎里，克里斯托弗·麦奎里和汤姆·克鲁斯，他们知道故事，他们知道那些宏大的动作场面。我刚拍完电影的剧本。什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？
What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What?
什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？
What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? story kind of organically, as we go. But there's so come the pages. I know, we get pages on the morning of shooting stuff. And I have to say, where have I been in the previous scene? And where am I going?
什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？故事是随着我们的拍摄自然发展的。但页面会发过来。我知道，我们在拍摄的当天早上才能拿到剧本。我不得不说，我在前一个场景里在哪里？我要去哪里？
And it can be frustrating, but it sort of works. And occasionally I get to kind of ad lib silly stuff. Like when we were shooting a scene for Fallout, when Tom was sort of guiding, I'm basically like a GPS, that's my job in the impossible, I just mean directions where Tom Cruise needs to go. And it was all the stuff about having the map upside down and the 3D thing, that was all kind of thrown in the moment. Oh, really?
这有时会让人沮丧，但它确实管用。而且我偶尔可以即兴发挥一些愚蠢的东西。就像我们在拍《碟中谍6：全面瓦解》的一个场景时，当时汤姆在引导，我基本上就像一个GPS，这就是我在《碟中谍》里的工作，我只是指引汤姆·克鲁斯需要去哪里。所有关于把地图拿倒和那个3D东西的桥段，都是当时即兴加进去的。哦，真的吗？
Macu is a brilliant writer, you know, he's an Oscar-winning writer, he wrote the usual suspects and... What an incredible director. He just somehow thrives in that situation. Incredible, amazing. I love, I am so in love with those mission impossible movies, What an incredible director. He just somehow thrives in that situation. Yeah. Incredible. I love, I am so in love with those mission impossible movies. All of them are so, they're always great.
麦奎是一个出色的编剧，你知道的，他是一个得过奥斯卡奖的编剧，他写过《非常嫌疑犯》还有……多么不可思议的导演。他不知怎么地就能在那种情况下游刃有余。不可思议，太棒了。我太爱了，我太喜欢那些《碟中谍》电影了，多么不可思议的导演。他不知怎么地就能在那种情况下游刃有余。是的。不可思议。我太爱了，我太喜欢那些《碟中谍》电影了。每一部都那么……它们总是那么棒。
They're so good. And you're always great in them. I mean, yeah, it's so hard, you're so great in them. And it's hard to believe that something that has that kind of scope, as Jason said, that's so good and complex and stuff that you guys would sort of improvise in that way or not really have a full understanding to me on something so big. I don't know, I tell you where that wouldn't wash is on the oceanic planet of Achtel.
它们太棒了。而且你在里面的表现总是那么棒。我是说，是的，这太难了，你在里面的表现太棒了。很难相信具有这种规模的东西，正如杰森所说，如此精彩和复杂，而你们竟然会以那种方式即兴创作，或者在这么大的项目上并没有真正完全理解。我不知道，我告诉你，这在阿克托（Achtel）这个海洋星球上是绝对行不通的。
No way. You can close the wiki window. No, you wouldn't wait, build the other way. Yeah, we should shut that window down. No, no. Well, on that note. Beautifully done. Simon, you are like a dream.
绝不可能。你可以关掉维基百科窗口了。不，你不会等一下，从另一边建。是的，我们应该把那个窗口关掉。不，不。好吧，借此机会。干得漂亮。西蒙，你就像个梦一样。
We take it too much of your time. This is so nice. I know, guys. I feel like we just got started. Let's keep going with this. I don't know. We can do it too, partner. I know, I know.
我们占用了你太多时间了。这太美妙了。我知道，伙计们。我觉得我们才刚开始。让我们继续聊下去吧。我不知道。我们也可以做到，搭档。我知道，我知道。
Will you say hi to Nick Frost, please? I will, I will. Get him on. Edgaron, I, you know, who put me onto this podcast was Naira Park, who, you know, just, she produced Paul and, yeah, yeah. Oh, yeah. She's Edgar and Edgar and my producer. She's done everything we've ever done.
请替我向尼克·弗罗斯特问好，好吗？我会的，我会的。把他请来。埃德加，我，你知道的，向我推荐这个播客的是奈拉·帕克，你知道的，她制作了《保罗》，而且，对，对。哦，对。她，埃德加和埃德加是我的制片人。她制作过我们拍过的所有作品。
And last year, she said, Oh, you listen to Smartness, right? And I said, Oh, and... So I had the whole of the back catalog to sort of like, which I literally have been like, every time I go to the gym or every time I go for a drive. It's just become like the soundtrack. And then, like, however recently, the idea of actually doing it came up.
去年她说，哦，你在听《聪明点》（SmartLess）吧？我说，哦，然后……所以我把以前的所有节目都听了一遍，我真的就像，每次我去健身房或者每次我开车的时候。它简直成了背景音乐。然后，在不久前，真正上这个节目的想法就被提出来了。
And, man, it's just so, I love you guys. I think you're so amazing. Have you ever got any ideas of people we should have on the show? Please let us know. Yeah. Yes, I'll send you some British people and you can do it. Please. Oh, it's great to see you, man.
天哪，这真是，我爱你们。我觉得你们太棒了。你们有没有想过我们应该请谁来节目？请告诉我们。好的。是的，我会给你们推荐一些英国人，你们可以邀请他们。求你了。哦，很高兴见到你，伙计。
Yeah. It's so nice to meet you, Simon, and such a fan. You too, Sean, it's a real pleasure. I'm serious about Comey's he could not ask her. I'd love to come see if I can. Anytime. Don't miss that. Yeah, you'll be blown away. Simon, we love you.
很高兴认识你，西蒙，我是你的超级粉丝。你也是，肖恩，真的很荣幸。我是认真的关于喜剧，他不可能……我很乐意来看看我能不能去。随时。别错过那个。是的，你会大开眼界的。西蒙，我们爱你。
Simon. Okay. We love you. We love you. We love you. We love you. You slam it. You slam it. Yeah., slam it. All right. You said it, man. Love you guys. Bye.
西蒙。好的。我们爱你。我们爱你。我们爱你。我们爱你。你太棒了。你太棒了。是的，太棒了。好吧。你说的对，伙计。爱你们，伙计们。再见。
Love you, buddy. Well, that's a, listen, that is a, that is a round peg and a round hole. Oh, nice. No. He said that peg's no square. No. What else? That's a really good actually.
爱你们，兄弟。嗯，听着，那真是一个萝卜一个坑。哦，太好了。不。他说那个坑不是方的。不。还有什么？这其实真的很不错。
Thanks, man. I'm coming up with a buy as we're, as we're talking. Are you there? I know what I'm thinking about is this friend of mine. I'm not kidding. This is not getting to a buy. This I've been trying to like connect the dots on. I was thinking about Scotty. Yeah. Because we were talking about Scotty. Yeah, I told him he I told him Simon Pag was going to be on the free top. And then remind me I never told you this because you might that I'm this is not a joke. One of my best buddies growing up is his name is Scotty Bear. And then I thought about your, I swear to God.
谢谢，伙计。我边说边想出一个笑话。你在听吗？我知道我在想什么，是我的另一个朋友。我没开玩笑。这不是在编笑话。我一直在试图把这些线索串联起来。我在想斯科蒂。对。因为我们在谈论斯科蒂。对，我告诉他，我告诉他西蒙·佩吉要上节目。然后提醒我，我从来没跟你说过这个，因为你可能会觉得这不是个笑话。我从小到大的一个好朋友，他的名字叫斯科蒂·贝尔（Scotty Bear）。然后我想到了你的，我发誓。
Oh really? Yes. That's funny because Scotty's a bear and you like bony bear. Right. So. I like Scotty's bone and bear. Yeah. So, wait, but Simon Pack, I've always wanted to meet him.
哦，真的吗？是的。这很有趣，因为斯科蒂是只熊（Bear），而你喜欢邦尼·贝尔（Bon Iver）。对吧。所以。我喜欢斯科蒂的骨头和熊。对。所以，等等，但是西蒙·佩吉，我一直想见他。
I can't believe you knew him. I didn't know you guys knew him. I knew you worked with him in Paul, Jay. meet him. I can't believe you knew him. I didn't know you guys knew him. I knew you worked with him in Paul, Jay. Yes. But I didn't know you knew him. He seems really fun. Jay's looking up a buy right now. So, I'm doing it.
我真不敢相信你认识他。我不知道你们认识他。我知道你和他在《保罗》里合作过，杰。见他。我真不敢相信你认识他。我不知道你们认识他。我知道你和他在《保罗》里合作过，杰。是的。但我不知道你认识他。他看起来真的很有趣。杰现在正在查一个笑话。所以，我在弄呢。
Yeah, I'm finding that my brain needs to completely shut down and focus on that and I can't hear you guys right now. Jay, JB, how fucking weird is that? So, remember, you thought it was a screening of hot fuzz and that I remembered it was a fucking screening of extract and I remember going to the restaurant next door with Mike Judge and you and Amy and Simon. What does that say?
是的，我发现我的大脑需要完全关闭并专注于那个，现在我听不到你们说话了。杰，JB，这他妈有多诡异？所以，记住，你以为那是《热血警探》的试映，而我记得那是《提取》的试映，我记得和迈克·贾吉、你、艾米还有西蒙一起去了隔壁的餐厅。那上面写了什么？
Is it say anything? I'm looking for something that might be good for me. Is there something good that I don't remember? It was a screening for me, my movie, that I'm thinking it was for him and his movie. Does that say something nice about me? No, are you trying to get me, like Brownie points? Trying to fill up my own ledger,
上面写了什么吗？我在找可能对我有用的东西。有什么对我有用、而我又不记得的好东西吗？那是为我举办的电影试映，我以为是为他和他的电影办的。那上面有没有说我的好话？不，你是在给我刷好感度吗？想为我自己的履历添砖加瓦，
on side the ledger. No, I don't get it. No. You know, when I was as a kid, I used to, fuck me, you know, Star Wars. You know, this is gonna be, by the way, it better be amazing, because you are like, oh, uh, yeah, you know, Star Wars, you know, this is going to be, by the way, it better be amazing because you are like, oh, for 40 right now. It's already lost.
在履历上。不，我不明白。不。你知道，当我还是个孩子的时候，我曾经，他妈的，你知道，《星球大战》。你知道，顺便说一句，这最好很惊艳，因为你就像，哦，呃，是的，你知道，《星球大战》，你知道，顺便说一句，这最好很惊艳，因为你就像，哦，大概40岁了。已经输了。
It's a good one. You know, when I was a kid, I was used to mix up the pronunciation of Luke Skywalker's mentor. I, I, I didn't know I didn't think it was Obi-Wan Kenobi. No, that's, no, no way. I thought it was. No way. I can't lie. No, it was Obi-Wan. no, no way. I thought it was no way. I can't buy.
这是一个好笑话。你知道，当我还是个孩子的时候，我总是把卢克·天行者的导师的发音弄混。我，我，我不知道我以为不是欧比旺·克诺比。不，那是，不，绝不可能。我以为是。绝不可能。我没撒谎。不，那是欧比旺。不，绝不可能。我买不起。
I thought it was oh by one. Oh by one. Oh, all by one can only be in two malls. What? What's it? Sean. Oh, by oh by one can only be one can only be in two malls. Was that our out?
我以为是欧·拜·旺（Oh by one）。欧·拜·旺。哦，所有欧·拜·旺只能在两个商场里。什么？怎么回事？肖恩。欧·拜……欧·拜·旺只能在两个商场里。那是我们的退路吗？
No. No. No. Smiles. Smiles. Smiles. Flies. Smiles is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Unjurf. Smiles. Flies. Janet Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Amjurf. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Smart, less. subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不。不。不。微笑。微笑。微笑。苍蝇。微笑是由贝内特·巴尔巴科（Bennett Barbaco）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·昂朱夫（Rob Unjurf）100%有机纯手工制作的。微笑。苍蝇。珍妮特·巴尔巴科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·安朱夫。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 ♪] [♪ 聪明，减少。在苹果播客或Wondry应用中订阅Wondry Plus。]本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。